and we are live the last word with lore
cognito and ibontis and the flyers tie
in the business thai guy travis and it's
a nice thursday man a lot of destiny
news let's start with e
what is going on sir
it has been one heck of a week for
destiny we knew it was gonna be we've
been talking about it for weeks about
the show but i don't even think i
expected everything that we got and
we're gonna break it all down
thoughts opinions it's going to be a
long show
um outside of destiny uh let's see i
cooked uh tasty dinner over the weekend
experimented with general so's chicken
the first time homemade
and then i also made the binging with
babish like the chocolate chip cookies
but like brown butter touch of cinnamon
uh more salt than you would expect but
it's like this really well balanced like
wait condiments
it's salt
condiment sir that that salt is not a
condiment
that's not even close
you actually put something to flavor
your food what flavor yes wow okay
anyways moving on i cooked some food
this weekend i had some tasty cookies
travis what you been up to bud
well my food isn't as bland and
caucasian as yours but i also ate some
good just you are sweet i'm just kidding
i'm just gonna be dry all right
that's true that's true i i could take
as well as i give that's right
um i'm doing well man this has been
what a week for destiny i'm just i'm
just ecstatic with all the news that's
going on it's really all i can think
about in fact
i'm so
happy about all the destiny news i've
only had a minimal amount of time to
react to all the halo news we got this
week which is also
pretty significant and some just dropped
right now
yeah they literally just dropped the
blog right now literally one of the devs
just just tweeted me and said yes it's
going down so it's bro it's this week
it's crazy so yeah more multiple all
your stuff multiplayer stuff and
everything so yeah go check it out the
halo vlog is up
how about you teddy what's going on wait
a minute is this the 21st step
you're going to give it back royalty we
got royalty we don't
talk to teddy as if he's some regular
individual okay we have to bring him in
right
[Laughter]
welcome to the last word episode number
164 and it's a glorious thursday and
we're back in front of the campfire for
some more lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our
returning guests so we're going to get
right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose
commitment to the minutia and technical
nature of the destiny franchise is only
matched by his pure passion for max
triumph score and flexing as an elite
controller user on pc
introducing one of our most passionate
and hardcore members of the destiny
community an astute warlock of clan
concern
a fellow friend of fire team chat
and through the law of averages keeps
his guest streak every 21 episodes
intact
live from cali and making his rightful
return at the campfire of the last word
my man lord teas and teddy how we doing
sir man those never get old
every time you give me one of those i go
to bed that night
it's like the best sleep i ever care
he's like yeah i just got that i got
that cognito valium shot and just like
going into dreamland
he stopped doing them for me teddy i
don't have to tell you
you know because i thought you were
being on the show enough that you would
just stop getting them but no you still
get them i just
every time he sees me he's just like
what's up travis
i hope that when i meet you in real life
eventually you're going to do that for
me in real life like like say you pick
me up from the airport i want you to
like announce me and now juventus yeah
i want to do one for cog i i
unfortunately i didn't know cog that
well when we had him on fire team shot
otherwise i would have definitely done
that for him that's cool man
we have a picture we have we've briefly
crossed paths sir remember that that's
true yeah
yeah lead controller there was a gcx
with e and you didn't get that yeah
[Laughter]
he had the uh the keyboard but other
than that like what's been going on with
you man i know you've been busy but
what's been going on man uh it's been
going you know life um i took a little
break at the end of last season because
there wasn't a whole lot going on and uh
now we're back in the new season and
it's a little bit more of the same but a
little bit different
so
it's not necessarily a bad thing but yes
uh just there's a lot a lot of other
stuff going on outside oh yeah oh yeah
absolutely
nice nice what about this other stuff e
trav oh there's gamescom like oh opening
night live so much going on um i am
worried for my sanity from january 21st
to february 22nd um because there's not
enough time in there to play all the
things i want to play elden right first
is eldon ring elden ring is the 21st oh
no
that's january 21st horizon zero before
witch queen verizon zero dawn is four
days before witch queen
yikes and then december starts this
thing we'll get to for the 30th
anniversary for this
sifu is on the 22nd the same day as
witch queen
oh shifu getting caught
i was like i know steve who's going
second place horizon comes out like four
days and it's over a weekend so i'm like
if i know life it and just take like two
weeks off of work maybe
but i'm also trying to figure i haven't
fully beaten horizon zero dawn so i've
been waiting for like my new monitor so
i can experience it on like pc and 4k
so like when i go through and play this
thing i'm gonna do it like fancy but i'm
like now i'm trying to figure out where
i'm gonna slot it in
so no i'm like ultra excited for
everything that's coming but i'm like
when did february become like
fall of night of like 2008 for gaming is
like hey everything comes out fall so
you can get in that black friday ad now
it's like
pick a month you never know if it's
going to be insane or not and i'm like i
don't have enough time
48 hours stream just don't sleep tape my
eyeballs open and beat horizon zero dawn
in a weekend then sleep for 24 hours
don't forget in the witch queen
don't forget with halo infinite
announced december 8. to be honest i'm
worried i won't even be done with halo
in time for which queen because halo for
me i mean that used to sustain me for
like years you know back when that was
the only game i could afford and
i i just can't imagine february 22nd
being around and being like oh yeah halo
i'm done playing that game every single
day like that just doesn't sound like me
so that one i'm worried about and then
put elden ring and all those other games
on top of it it's gonna be nuts also
don't forget god of war is coming out
that that i think it's somewhere around
that window isn't that february
later yeah
we're hoping for a delay
like they wouldn't do horizon gotta wear
that close together
like god of war like if they're ever
waiting for anything god of war no i
would bet that's their holiday release
to just like their their banger
fall oh they said spring spring 2022.
that's where they come out in the early
half oh i don't hold my breath on that
one until you see more on it because
horizon got pushed yeah far enough yeah
and then with with kohl's impressed in
development in the covid right now
yeah i find it very hard to believe that
they would uh cannibalize their release
with next to horizon forbidden west but
we'll see we'll see what happens man but
next year i saw the horizon i was like
poi i was like all his loves his
passions all at the same time i was like
yeah well like elder ring i am playing
100 but that gives me a month i'm like i
can work with a month but man horizon
the only problem with horizon is now i
don't think there's anything like breath
of the wild next to horizon right now so
at least it's not getting a breath of
the wild again
but still it's like yeah for me
again destiny is going to pull me away
from horizon because they did it last
time
and we saw what they got to offer which
we will talk about
what about you guys like what have you
seen in gamescom because i know
these two other awesome gentlemen cover
it a bit more uh it's part of the job
sometimes so what have you guys seen
maybe didn't get you know fell through
the cracks a little bit you know
do you like the uh you know forza
horizon 5 plane drop of the bronco
actually when that happened i uh so we
we clip out stuff during the
the uh live streams yeah i was like oh
there's a straight up taking this out of
uh fast and furious
yeah and i'm like
and then immediately i was like but you
can't steer the car while it's being
parachuted
so how are they landing specifically
where they need to land like in the
movie oh you got those little cords you
know just outside the window you're
pulling them i i just i
they do it with gps in a fast and
furious movie we really want to go there
so is that a gps coordinate yeah that's
how they do it in the movie but how is
the car like
you know there's like air and wind and
other
factors it's the it's the parachute is
basically like
aiming for a spot it's going to say they
went to space they put little like star
trek thrusters on this thing so it's
automatically adjusting the entire way
down and then it lands perfectly please
spoilers bro that movie's still pretty
new
i'm pretty sure that's in the trailer or
something like it's not oh i swear i
thought it was back they held it back i
heard it for the longest time so i
wasn't i was like when are they so
finally rumors
it's on video now i think we're okay
so
that's true video whatever it is
video now
home release is what i call it yeah
that's fair i still remember when i used
to order movies on amazon and every so
often like the delivery cycle would get
and i would get one
like a day early and i'd like be excited
because i got like a marvel movie a day
or something like i got a big release
like a big deal i got it like on
thursday instead of friday when it's
supposed to be delivered i was like i
was freaking out i was like yeah
it's like
hiding it behind another game so if you
come back three days later yeah you're
like yeah i want this one to be here but
i can't get two games right now i can
only get one so i'm gonna stick this one
behind like the 90s bad you know b-movie
over here in this section
rental culture i had a good old days
we're all too old that's all that was
like started putting envelopes in the
mail envelope that was an option that
wasn't still an option apparently
apparently they still have that much
yeah a lot of their a lot of their stuff
if you look at the stream if they don't
have it they'll be like this is
available via our physical disk service
and they'll try to get you to do that
but it's like wow
you have to yeah that's a little bit of
an upcharge service
my wife's parents had that for the
longest time after like i mean i used it
for a while but my wife's parents had
that for
so long we'd go up there and be like
what is this netflix disc doing why why
do you have this and it's like a couple
years ago like is this still a thing but
they're like yep sure enough yeah i
don't know if there's a red box dude
that one is bizarre to me the red box
and like the grocery store that you know
that one i actually use because you use
that well there's like a walmart
neighborhood market like literally three
minutes up the road for me and every so
often if i just want like i want a
blu-ray disc for something i'm like yeah
you know it might be like like nobody i
didn't see it in theaters but like
something a little more action and i'm
like i want the disc for a little higher
quality i'll be like i'll just pop up
there it's like a dollar 25 and i'm out
it's cheaper than streaming and it's
gonna be better quality yeah oh
can i ask you a question that's probably
gonna make me seem like a san francisco
elitist i mean probably
what what is a walmart neighborhood
market
so basically tell them take walmart
if you okay do you know what a walmart
super center is
no no okay you wouldn't have mart is
actually banned in the san francisco
area okay fair enough oh wow that's
right for like union busting reasons
yeah yeah so i mean walmart generally
you picture it's just kind of like a mix
all of everything but not a major
grocery section
well walmart super center is like half
grocery
half walmart for like automotive goods
sporting you know mix of everything if
you take out the other stuff yeah it's
basically like a walmart grocery store
it's like a grocery store right walmart
label pretty much got you yeah
it doesn't have all the other stuff it's
a grocery focus walmart like dope
massachusetts but it's also a way for
like walmart to put their brand probably
like right next to like a residential
area houses where you can't probably
plant you know a commercial building
it's more of a grocery store for
proximity so it gets away with both and
every so often there's like one thing
that they'll have and i'm like it's kind
of nice that it's still there
yeah
salute salute yeah joys of living in the
dallas suburbs there's a whole lot of
random crap around here
what are you gonna do
but i kind of was gonna go back to the
question for gamescom what what did you
guys see over the course of this past
like kind of 48 hours of insanity what
else have you guys seen besides destiny
which we're going to talk about what
else have you guys seen that has you
guys pumped
gentlemen any uh standouts i think teddy
okay there was nothing really
i don't know there was there wasn't a
whole lot there was
actually
there was a couple things that that were
on jeff's stage that
caught my eye i don't know the names
specifically but they were kind of like
minor um not indeed per se but like
mine i have to go back when we're
clipping stuff out everything's
happening so fast so sometimes like i
don't get a chance to actually like see
the thing
um like i'm just listening occasionally
to it and then that's it
um
so i'd have to go back there
was a big one uh
never never didn't care about that
they did a far cry 6 thing which i think
was like one of their longer trailers um
we got the legendary man with the
millionaires in the chat right now yeah
call of duty actually looks pretty good
you get there you get there
shout out way too
quick shout out to rand al thor
in chat thank you very much sir uh for
the five dollar super chat gentlemen
there's something to the bunchy 30th
anniversary being on december 7th and
then the very next day halo infinite
launches was this planned you guys have
thoughts for the halo experts
so
yeah here we go um
there we actually talked about this on
fire team chat and paul tassie and i
talked about it
and
apparently we have some uh industry
anonymous confirmation that uh
destiny was in talks with the 343 team
bungie and 343 were talking about
halo
that was confirmed however the talks
sort of basically they didn't fall
through they just didn't make it in time
and then that stuff didn't happen so the
halo stuff that's in the 30th
anniversary is like
alluding to halo but it's not halo
specific like the armor has like some
needles
yeah that's it like they there's no like
master chief armor and i don't think the
uh exotic magnum is making at that time
so i think maybe the um
i think maybe the reason that the timing
matches up is because they were going
for something like that but from what
i've heard both from paul and from my
own sources is that that that didn't uh
come together so gotcha what if it's a
development thing too because we we do
know with 343 obviously you know the
campaign the co-op campaign got cut
forward got cut
yeah i i try to get this thing across
the finish line as much as possible i
wonder with development those initial
plans just kind of had to fall by the
wayside to me but i do find it
interesting that december lined up with
you know bungee anniversary halo
anniversary and the fact that you know
it doesn't look like halo is going to
miss 2021 like halo's coming out
regardless
that's kind of what i've said like some
i was talking to
one or two on twitter and basically
it seems more and more like
somewhere somebody said just like halo
like you something is happening halo
related in 21
whatever you've got we're taking it and
then you can do what you want to do with
the rest but it's just like some however
far up it went somebody was like
something halo is this year like make it
happen so that's one of those because it
seems like i mean you've heard the
backlash like co-op campaign or not and
i'm like i'm gonna play everything solo
but i know it's also in this that like a
lot of people of the generation who want
halo also played at co-op and then forge
can be a big thing for the life of the
game six months i mean you hear all
these debates and everything but it's
like yeah then when you see like little
things here and there it's like then
when you see it's december and people
worried about call of duty in november
and stuff like that it's like
they're just trying to make 21 on the
end of that date it seems like at this
point i i agree
is gonna say something like he was ready
to say something um i guess before we
continue
what is the uh policy regarding the all
but confirmed leaks that have come out
with destiny that uh the paste bin yeah
the paper talk about that on this
podcast you guys saw i got
towards the very very end please yeah
okay so i just i just won't reference
anything yeah we'll we'll talk facebook
at the end but
although teddy i don't really trust the
paceman anymore because like half of
that was wrong yes
yes
wrong
it was a lot right it was a lot right it
was a lot it was a lot right but there
was a lot of new rats
know his first favorite word is fake
analytics but now shout out there was a
shout out to you right now there was a
lot wrong there but i got to come for
him on something else later get into the
store oh sisters
exactly we'll get there he's my
stay right there with that energy sir
i've been waiting for you continue
i was like i was just gonna say it's
it's it's been a very exciting couple of
days between gaming announcements game
trailers by the way anybody else like
insanely kind of blown away for black
myth with wukong oh excuse me yeah
no bro i've that i've been on that train
for now are you going to the moment
yeah no that that's the one i'm going to
do as far as the dark souls whatever
whatever because of the mythology and
you know me the ninja you know how i get
down and
they're gonna sucker me into that one
because that one oh my it is it is this
is the thing you must stream
[Laughter]
this is going to go back to what we
talked about on twitter if you want to
see people struggle doing 50 vault of
glasses and not getting vex i want to
see you struggle playing a souls game
publicly
they've seen me struggle not getting
texts
that's enough pain i don't put teddy
through pain i don't put travis through
pain no no one needs to see my pain in
this game i'll gladly watch you though
i'm glad you watch you you mean you make
you make me listen to you talking about
how warlocks are good all the time you
don't think that's gonna be
teddy's over there like whoa like i got
my very teddy movie i'm good right now
i'm good
they're the best there was a midnight
suns game at gamescom yes
yes yes
is that like a x-con with a different
x-com with like a different noise it's a
turn a turn-based rpg that apparently
does not have a lot in common with x-com
it's not like yeah based on turn-based
rfg and the interesting thing was they
said that you like build relationships
with the characters so it sounds like it
has like a mass effect 2 dating sim kind
of like element to it which like that's
kind of dope to be honest like marvel
characters you can you can uh
choose to
work with and build relationships with
i'm down with that listen you know i
knew we kind of i kind of knew the
rumors were happening you know so that
was it a little indie one it was like
midnight
express something that looked really
cool
you know obviously you know the big
stuff that got announced um
i'm not the biggest saints row guy but i
was like okay i've seen that and um yeah
halo i mean we got the date we got the
date i don't know why
xbox didn't release that on their show
but that's another okay or at least just
be like hey hey tune in to tomorrow the
jeff's show like this is your biggest
franchise and you'd not choose to
mention it on your but they want to show
us trebuchets trebuchets and the history
channel on their show played age of
empires in so long but i heard they
talked about that for so long i'm like
what what are you doing with your time
like this is a weird
candidate i actually appreciated that to
be honest because
i xbox has always been like more
community focused than other developers
where like they want to be a part of
like e3 and like be a pillar in it and
they want to like be featured at the
game awards and they want to be featured
at gamescom's like opening night and
then i think they're using their own
separate shows to do like deep dives on
their games for people who care enough
right but unlike the big stages xbox has
shown that like they want to be there
and participate and like
give a little bit of their coverage to
those events so i get what they did like
they had they saved the halo reveal for
the bigger show which yeah it was a
business decision i understand it like i
said we're just surprising
like teddy said no mention like hey
tune in tomorrow and show you
the helmet that's literally all they had
to do was like i gotta do it like
then bridgette just bridge it but to
leave people who just was looking for
that a little bit there was like yeah
there was like 24 hours of like uh
okay got it like so no halo yeah no yeah
agreed yeah someone someone that works
in production
uh occasionally when we have events like
that's something that you like normally
would do right you know the the toss or
the you know tune in later so you keep
your eyes right engaged called action
yeah yeah and they just they just didn't
uh
yeah it's just weird not even like
now what i did hear or try i mean trap
teddy was that um
that was pre-recorded
uh that show was like
pre-recorded yeah so that may have
that's only but still
i still feel it's on them social media
wise or whatever wise people talk
something at the end it's like you put a
graphic yeah something you gotta do
edit the last little thing be like tune
in tomorrow and just like yeah show a
ring whatever it's the tiniest little
thing and people blow their minds like
that's not that hard
i'm with y'all i'm with you so uh
actually how about that
how many of you guys are so bad did you
guys get like seven of those controllers
yeah
it was so bad we did a live stream and
when they announced it i stopped talking
to the to the people and i was on i was
doing a teddy i had all the websites up
i i like i was determined i completely
disconnected mentally from a live stream
with fans that's the focus on getting it
and i got it so i'm good man did you
guys did you get a second series x as
well
i could i wanted i couldn't justify it i
was like
cog stop stop [ __ ] like it's it's
literally how many did you get
one of each
um respect but
i
lie
i'll probably give
i'll probably give the uh the console to
my brother um because he's more of a
halo fan than i am but also i kind of
feel it's a little bit scummy for them
to release
a
cus you know custom console one year
after the launch when like clearly you
know this game was supposed to come out
last year yeah so so like the the
business side of me thinks that this was
already made and this has just been
sitting in a warehouse somewhere yeah at
least they already have the design 100
okay i i already bought the console man
if you like if they had told me last
year this was coming out just don't even
show it just tell me there's going to be
a halo console i would have not just i
wouldn't have bought or just
um
so that kind of sucks but otherwise the
console looks amazing yeah console looks
like probably 50 more for anything or is
it just 50.
you get the game yeah okay okay that's
fair um yeah if it's 50 bucks more for
the game that's the deal that's fine
yeah you're technically just paying for
the game at that point um assuming you
can get one because i i think that this
console wouldn't have happened without
the delay teddy because i don't think
i don't think you release a special
edition of the console when because
remember halo was supposed to be a
launch release for the series x and i
don't think they would have launched
with a special edition of the xbox so i
i think it was like oh well we're going
to wait another normal times they might
have they might have done like a limited
run but if like with all the
restrictions and supply chains
they did uh they did the project scorpio
yeah i mean it wasn't like yeah because
i have the day one xbox one like
literally says day one on the controller
i have that one yeah
yeah that that's i wouldn't say that's
like a special edition but i guess you
know i mean
yeah i think it probably wouldn't have
happened but like with the limits of
like nobody can get their hands on
consoles so they just probably buy
whatever you can yeah i mean they phil
spencer at least in a couple interviews
has been pretty honest about um how
involved microsoft has been in the
supply supply chain supply chain which
is something that normally a they don't
directly deal with and b they don't also
talk about but because of all the
limitations and all the shortages and
everything which are going to continue
into 2023 or 20.2
um
then uh
yeah it's just yeah
people are talking in the comments about
the elite controller and the reliability
issues and i know you and i have had
really long heart to heart so maybe we
should say it's a psa to the people in
the comments about the elite controllers
and the proper way to manage your elite
your relationship with your elite
controller well so here's the thing i
every time i pick up my controller
before i play i wash my hands and i
clean the controller
i've been doing this for years because i
absolutely hate gunky controllers
it drives me up the wall
uh and they look like how would you rate
the controllers at my home that you use
very clean
exactly because just like mine care
about our hardware right we clean it
regularly but more important than that
the elite series to even the two
do you have problems because there's so
many moving parts so the only issue i've
had with mine the series one i had
issues with the sticks drifting after a
while but i always had the best buy
warranty so it was really easy oh yes
um i worked there so the warranty was
like two dollars oh it was the greatest
thing oh yeah it was so dumb
um
there was even at one point i replaced
it on the
first year 364th day nothing was wrong
with that i was like i might as well
replace it
um and get another one because the
warranty was only like two bucks so
right before i quit and then the series
two came out but uh to answer your
question the
the only problem i've had with the
series two specifically because i just
replaced my first one uh was the one of
the bumpers um
would not click fully and it was really
annoying in destiny so what i ended up
doing
uh was i actually mapped my super to
double press the other bumper instead of
having to press both of them because
what was happening was i pressed both
and then it would do my male error mark
grenade it wouldn't do the
thing and now now i've actually adopted
that that um
that usage now that we have like full
remapping and everything like yeah we'll
get into later but yeah um that's the
only issue i've had with the series two
i have heard of other more technical
issues that people have had and they
seem like they're legitimate um hardware
issues it's not like user error or user
usage yeah uh
and i don't know if they've issued a
revision without telling anyone because
they do that over time one as well
there's there's lots of versions of it
um
or they haven't really i can tell you
all the all the issues i've had with the
series 2 have been pretty minor but when
they do happen i just turn it in for a
new one on best fly because i think
that's the problem people make is they
buy it and it comes with a 90 day
warranty which is ridiculous on the 200
item yeah and then when it inevitably
breaks you know five or six months later
or years later people get really pissed
off and i just say dude just buy a best
buy one best buy best buy get the
warranty it's fully covered and then
what i do is anytime i have an issue
even if it's tiny miner i turn it in and
i buy a new uh i buy a new warranty for
30 bucks yeah and then i just keep it
going keep it going anytime it breaks
you just pay a little 30 bucks and keep
it going so my recommendation is best
buy has got a racket going wash your
hands wash the controller and
buy the warranty because honestly the
the warranty that ships with it is not
not good we're gonna need to get you
guys like disassembly kits send that
thing through dishwasher for a deep
clean put it back together
every six months reassemble and clear
i'm done
i joke about the dishwasher but i heard
you can actually put keyboards in there
uh you can most uh most keyboards you
can put in your dishwasher and they'll
usually be fine
yeah that that cracked me up one time i
haven't done it yet but i heard that was
a real thing but there's this other game
yes there's a game i think now right so
i'm gonna have time i'm gonna put a
little intro to this one be like about
30 minutes in we get the destiny but we
had the we had the crew we had to catch
up told you guys this was going to be a
long freaking show
which queen
we have the reveal for
so much and honestly they started the
day before with a little baby 15 second
trailer of savithoon talking and we
actually get to hear savithoon talking
which is really really cool but
before i go through all of the nitty
gritty of everything that we know about
the witch queen so far
just basically want to get everybody's
thoughts about high level don't go too
nitty on anything
uh teddy first just like
level your your level uh when you were
done with the showcase where were you at
uh overall pretty excited um as we kind
of alluded to earlier because of the
leak most of the stuff uh
kind of got confirmed so i already knew
what was coming but it was cool to
actually see it because it's one thing
to read it on a piece of paper or our
digital screen and then and then it's
another to actually see because bungie's
world building is just um and their
world artists are just so incredible
and it just looks
awesome like uh it gives me
uh taken king vibes like it's the same
feeling i got with taking king
not because it's high related but just
like the sheer scale of it and also um
the gravity of what's happening uh is
also kind of that taking king level like
we we haven't really gotten that since
taking king forsaken was kind of was
kind of close but um
overall very happy very excited i am
also pleasantly happy that the season is
extended
um i would have totally been fine if the
anniversary stuff didn't come and just
they just gave us like a month or two to
kind of chill yeah but uh that's even
better too like
cool um
but yeah very excited probably like a
nine in terms of nice nice nice nice
where you at
or where were you i guess tuesday
i still am there man i haven't left i'm
very excited i i'm i'm both excited
about the stuff that they've already
changed in the game like the fact that
uh having infinite primary ammo has oh
man changed us oh yeah yeah possible way
honestly
um stuff like that and then also just
for
not just the stuff we saw for witch
queen and for the 30th anniversary of
the stuff that we're getting soon but
the stuff that they told us about like
the final shape and all of the stuff
that they're talking about in the future
keeping destiny going after the darkness
all that stuff was so super super
awesome so i'm definitely in a nine
the only reason i'm not a 10 is because
the leaks sort of took a little bit of
the window of the sale and in some areas
i have more questions than answers oh
uh not not in a good way like uh trials
matchmaking which i uh i listened to
so yeah we'll get to that
i'm still a skeptic about trials but we
can talk about that later travis and his
skepticism
a lot of thoughts about that the ninja
where was where was the ninja
did the ninja take off the mask and
reveal his true feelings
it was a live stream it was
listen um
i said coming in
i'm not tempering expectation
because one thing i've learned with
being loyal to this damn game
is when their back is against the wall
they always deliver we have to give them
that and you know everybody's like yo
the pressure's on personal he's like yo
we have to temp no
i had faith and boy they exceeded my
expectation just for that trailer alone
i thought off got the actress sir
deborah something
very very cold very very chilling and i
loved the line she was like you know
where's your truth now and when you saw
the hive ghosts come in
i'm like oh no this is disrespectful i
don't believe they're doing this i don't
believe they're doing this they have the
light like it was chilling the other
cinematic was amazing the musical choice
was amazing um
the disrespect of hive using our powers
against us in subclasses was absolutely
like wow i can't believe they're doing
it
again the um
the the marketing team
needs to literally get a raise like they
are the backbone of this game like
anybody who watches trailers besides the
don't get me wrong the weapon design
team the game the gun play we get it
but
nothing gets the juices flowing
then a destiny trailer even if even on a
a wack season
watch the trailer and you'll be like yo
i'm kind of hyped just to see what's
going to happen season of the world
season of the unworthy we joke about the
season of the worthy trailer still loved
it
still loved it they always do it whether
it be the like i said the the the
dramatic you know
anchor to it and like like um teddy said
it was like
you you feel that taking a kid vibe like
you feel fear again like it is something
about the only the only concern i have
with them long term is just that like
the hive is such a good
enemy
type a good race to to invoke fear and
bless you and devote fear and to really
get emotional like when she jumped out
the and she did the the spider-man thing
yeah bro i was just like yo i need that
wallpaper fan you know saying like so
again my only concern is just like in
future
can they ever
get anything to match the hive and how
that makes you feel you know in general
as an enemy type and stuff like that but
it was phenomenal we'll get into the to
the details of nitty gritty and stuff
like that but um yeah overall just a
trailer and everything announced was
phenomenal but e
where were you
what was going on my tempering of
expectations went completely out the
window the day before with the 15
seconds
15 seconds like holy [ __ ] i was like i
threw it all i was like nah i'm here i'm
ready and then on my live stream i was
just like yo what i probably was like my
wife was like are you yelling a couple
times i'm like
say i live stream the whole team shout
out to like the 200 people that were in
my live stream that day like all of you
guys were fantastic um
now that was so much um
more than i expected hadn't seen i've
heard little bits and pieces from leaks
here and there things get tossed around
i don't try and dodge everything but i
try and dodge some
and we expected
obviously something a new destination
but what everybody's like old chicago
is this the rumor
you can kind of see where old chicago
might have tied into where we're going
that's like a thing we'll get to in a
little bit um
but the way as you said they twisted it
on its head and i think we'll get into
why we have
hive that can do what they can do
um
but also why we don't have something a
lot of people expected in the category
of the green color well we don't have
something like all of these things we
figured in the last like 48 hours have
been crazy but they
they made the absolute best of any like
hey this situation might not be the best
thing to do right now done really mad
they turned it on its head and were like
let's have a whole lot of fun with this
one and just completely flip so
no i love hearing like the voice actress
for savithoon can't wait to hear more
there just the way it's like spoken and
you actually see you can hear her in
this season too and she's great oh yeah
she's great
did not expect that one to get to um but
just overall
i mean when i got done
i lost my mind i'm probably out of nine
as well because i'm with you guys on
like questions of things
one of mine is a giant missing factor
which i'll get to where i'm missing
something but we'll get to that vapor
what
vapor
vapor
the uh the new element that was
you know corrosion or green or whatever
no not even that no mine's mine's a very
simple thing that i've talked about
before but we'll get to that but
i would definitely say like when it
comes to
this reveal like the cg trailer the
discussion they had the hype of just
everybody in the studio talking shout
out to everybody on stage shout out to
tom's farm farmsworth and stuff that was
up there
yeah i'm missing all the names those are
the ones that just pop into my head but
all of them did so so well what's up
also we forgot to me which is really
cool and um oh the pre-show the pre-show
because like that was such a cool touch
and very emotional like i was just like
wow that was they didn't have to do that
and when i mean obviously i think our
names are called but i just know what it
feels like to see as a content creator
like to see your name like that
that hits that hits hard man that salute
to them for that because it also it
almost took me back to
booting up
destiny to vanilla for the first time
yeah what the hell and
you see you see
your previous raids that you completed
the names of the fire team members
and for me it was emotional because you
know some you know god bless you know
have passed away and i remember i'm like
wow
i did that raid you know my homie
whiskey wow i did king's fall with this
perk like just seeing old names stuff
like that so yeah i love when they do
these kind of callbacks and for this
stream to celebrate the community and
the way they did was a beautiful touch
and obviously halo anniversary well i
got a lot it was a lot of times e
but your boy was like damn dude like
excuse me yeah yeah
there's a bug in my i'm sorry yeah like
you like damn i've been through this
game so long and to see them pay it
forward was just well done the touches
the music we even see the young deej in
there
we said a baby face we like wow this is
a deeds back in the day like
they phenomenal job phenomenal job the
fields were all full display and i don't
want to not mention that because they
deserve a lot of credit for that one no
i was like that's something to point out
because over the course of e3s and other
things
i think somebody was like hey we can do
a pre-show just to hype up marketing
numbers i'm like they that's kind of
what that was like every day you have a
pre-show i'm like what is the pre is it
gonna be an hour of like looking at
screenshots or little animations and
stuff like that and it's like
you know i know other companies are like
hey it's not a
you know it's a marketing thing but i'm
like yeah you boosted your numbers for
the last six hours before you show us
the 20 20 minute trailer
they took that time for when they made
it only an hour and two they made like
the absolute like they did something
special with that which i really liked
how they took
what probably was a bit of a marketing
build up the numbers for the reveal but
did a really really cool thing for the
community which again shows they're
i mean you said they got marketing
they've got awesome developers like
artists and everything but the way they
handle their community is still second
to none yeah that's always impressive
yeah the second i know for sure the
jason jones interview was the time
that was really cool
that conversation the moment where he
talks about hearing those halo players
on the bus
and hearing them talk about like how
they were admitting that they liked each
other through the game as like a way to
express the strength of their friendship
i was just like damn like that's
powerful like he's like realizing all
his
energy and the pursuit of his life
through like these other people and i
can you know i'm like i'm a game master
so like i've created moments like that
where like my players have just like had
a life-changing experience and talk
about it and like i know that feeling
like that kind of like i helped bring
these people together like that that's
uh i'll do what you need for them it's
super powerful so
yeah i guess all content creators have
probably experienced something like that
right so i'm pretty sure everyone in
this this chat has felt that way no
doubt um yeah that was super powerful
for me just seeing that
good honor man bungie's bungie's awesome
happy 30th it's also rare that he does
an interview he's pretty uh yes
he's very parson's even less
yeah even less did you see the one there
were two words from pete parsons and i
appreciated that they were great words
great words i love that yeah those are
capri has an interview with that guy so
ah
i have to dig for that one then
it's like one of his only interviews the
legend subscribe ryan gets man
give him a high five because he gets
and i always like ryan
styles questions research he goes into
every one of those that i've listened to
well just each one's well done yeah
extremely well filtered is one of the
best one of the best things yes ever and
it doesn't get the credit it deserves i
feel it pisses me off because what he
does he like i said he he's been doing
it for so long
he we need to give him his flowers
it's a passion project for him yes
yeah it's not yeah it's not necessarily
like a just performing yep i agree
i'm glad he gets to because it's worth
listening to
yes
but i'm going to be reading some of this
verbatim because i don't want to mess it
up but we're going to go through all the
details of the big witch queen website
now and talk about this in pieces um
obviously the survive the truth is the
big name of the reveal
sister of [ __ ] i think that means
survive the truth
honestly like we'll get to that and see
lost i think but i mean what do you
think it means i guess we'll start there
survive the truth i think
i think the truth is that humans aren't
special and i think that the traveler is
going to willingly give the light to the
hive and i think that's what the truth
is
i think the truth is that the travelers
a morally gray character it sort of just
gives the light to anybody who proves
themselves worthy and doesn't really
care about who's on the side of good or
not and i think that's going to be the
truth of that season that's that's what
i think it is just totally so it's gonna
be season of the truth
i i think uh it'll probably be seasonal
the witch queen or something you know
lame like that but yeah i don't my guess
is that
the
the truth is is that
just if you listen to
her monologue yes again with the chili
in mind yes good point she didn't she
didn't do this by like taking it she did
it just by
like bringing she almost brought us low
by showing that the hive could be just
as worthy the only thing keeping them
from doing it was that they're packed
with the worms and the darkness and all
that so
um that's just my theory based on the
way that she's been speaking to us is
that she has a plan and her plan is to
almost like bring guardians down to her
level right and be like yo like and we
could be bearers of the light too
and and that's i think that's like a
powerful message of like realizing that
we're not special that's my theory
that's kind of funny tell me what you do
tell me what you think man
so they they've been hinting
for quite a while now since like after
forsaken that um the line they keep
repeating is the the line between light
and dark is is very thin
and and we've kind of seen that now with
beyond light where we you know we've
crossed over uh and so i think to
travis's point um
yeah i think the traveler
it is very ambiguous uh and we've just
always assumed that like oh the
travelers you know it's the light it's
this it's it's all good it's all knowing
but it's really not it's just kind of
picked us out of convenience because
you know we happened to be where
um the last stand was taken you know
we're doing the collapse or whatever and
it tried to leave us let's not forget it
did try to leave
um and goal was the reason that it uh
it didn't leave um
and then and then it was you know
re-awoken or whatever that's that's
what's set off all the events that's
been happening since the beginning of g2
yep um
i do think that with savathune
um
she
she's trying
to somehow
rid herself of of the burden that that
hai face which is this this constant
need to
uh feed their work
uh i believe there was some text either
from oryx or zevo wrath that also
kind of hints at this where they they
don't view it as like this power but
more of a it's a it's artists yeah and
her being the uh sort of cunning the
intellect
of the three i feel like that is
ultimately her goal and so this true
thing that she's trying what kind of
travis said that she's trying to make
his face is that um
once she maybe i don't know potentially
gets rid of that
uh
that burden then then she's she's uh
open to
or able to accept the light um or maybe
she'll trick the traveler i i don't know
it could be the other option as far as
um
yes i think the traveler's gonna do it
on his own that's my theory
[Music]
yeah i
i just lost my thought
cheers
you're good you're good
i think that they uh
i forgot i'm yeah you're good bro
i was gonna say something about like how
she wants us to to believe one thing but
not but i i totally forgot the point but
i mean she is like
she's in general for this entire
franchise been kind of the behind the
scenes puppet master of deception that's
her whole setting up the dominoes to
fall
you know playing with osiris and using
that character of power to do things but
then she tells you
what she did with you know i did good
all the stuff that we got in this like
first five seconds of this season has
been like oh
um but all these things we get about her
are very interesting but again she's
very very deceptive at everything that
she does so how can you really believe
what's going on and this season that
we're currently in now which we'll talk
about a little bit later is weird
because what we're doing now and what we
see here as we're like we're getting to
to that we're going there
there's a lot that has to happen to get
there to get her to be in that state so
it's like i'm
i get why the reveal of season of the
lost and the two had to happen together
now yeah because like if you showed one
you're like well
and then it's like now we're in the
season that we're in so i kind of
figured that's how it was going to be we
talked about that i knew they had to
have some connection it's very very big
connection at this point
um
but i mean as for survive of the truth
i'm still wondering yeah as you guys are
saying what is
what's up with the light and we'll get
into that because the light is
you know what is the line something so
very thin
oh the yeah
the light between lightning
is very thin right and that's i mean you
know we got stasis which is like okay we
got that from the pyramid ships but she
was trying that now it's like well she
was like i was trying to protect you
from working with them and then we did
that and then the tree of
um silver tree of silver wings and all
just all of the stuff that's been
building i'm like
they're they're on the precipice of
something really amazing and i just
can't wait until we get there so overall
yeah
i think i think we'll get there this
season too i think like i think before
the season's up the the transformation
is complete for the the uh
at the very at the very least like
something's gonna happen because i don't
know how much
how much cinematic we're gonna get when
the witch queen opens i feel like this
is their opportunity to tell the story
and so that when
you get to the witch queen you just sort
of get to jump right into whatever that
conflict is you hope that that's what
happens yeah and then we still have the
you know this evil a wrath situation
right we still
have to get clarity with that which is a
sister and you know
not i don't know if we're going with a
seasonal loss right now i don't want to
get too far with it but
like it's kind of overlapping which is
hard so i mean yeah okay so yeah so i
was like i'm trying to keep them
separate and go through which coin stuff
but you if we're then the lord bit you
can talk about it because i mean
seasonal loss is what it is right now
because of that and that's why it's a
giant question for me is like how do we
get to there because of zebu doing what
she's doing right now
and and to me it feels like this
you know sibling power struggle and the
the manipulation of savithoon
to tomorrow you know to get her to do so
to me the way i've used sabbath so far
is
you know using things for everything is
a means to an end like every every
thing she comes in contact with for some
in my opinion it feels like to utilize
to get somewhere to the next would make
that end game may you know maybe what we
saw with the witch queen revealed right
so which is them receiving the light but
i like travis's thought which is um
about the whole
you know
the morality of the traveler right which
is maybe there is none you know say it
it's it's its own it's just like you
said morally gray area because the
fallen had it at one point right the
fallen one where we'll just of the light
you know elixir and stuff like that so
it is very interesting to see where
they're going i like that theory by
travis i i just i'm very curious to see
in this season narratively how that
transitions in
and
oh by the record no more suspicious
y'all so we're going to stop that
now so for all the people who were
the great name it is now officially
revealed
with the ooga booga well she did the
booga figures which i liked thank you i
told you it was gonna
and for all the people who who chastise
no cog it's no way
it's it's it's really him
no
the lord that was in the game literally
said she was taking a form it was hard
to maintain that form which was osiris
that now we're doing some trade-offs
supposedly i think sadly i think my
man's dead but
you know you know i have to keep it a
buck you know i'm saying she ain't she's
the witch queen of deception my man is
probably six feet under with no goals
she's probably a rap but she's gonna
yeah yeah it's a wrap so it's probably
to to get us to do this worm god worm
thing for her to get her ultimate goal
and then she'll probably go and betray
us again and whatever whatever but i had
to clear the air because i've been
chastised i've been abused new red
[Laughter]
but many people
not my community
listen i like do right i do rest at home
you know what i was just saying
but at the end of the day at the end of
the day it is it is interesting and i i
sadly i think yeah he's going to be
sacrificed i just hope he get a nice
little shout out maybe maybe like a
scene with saint to see him before he
goes
you know maybe i get that that's what
i'm hoping for at this point but i hope
we get the worst of both worlds i hope
not only do we not get a cool death
scene but right before he dies he goes i
would have betrayed if you just died
i just want one heroic
last breath moment
that you know what i just want to see
all the supers at the same time and then
go out like a blaze of glory and then
die yeah go out like a g go out like a g
you know what i'm saying and maybe you
know
the weird twist about it e though is
remember
he his whole life
went to stop
saints death
think about that and now saints trying
to stop his now so that is a cool
parallel if they narratively want to do
that you know what i'm saying is it
would be interesting you know what i
mean because those two have that
interesting history like the sundial was
built to break space and time to save
this you know the same hobby the same
debut thing you know what i'm saying so
it would be interesting if satan is like
nah we gonna do something with this
we got to bring my phoenix back that
would be interesting to see but that's
all i had to say you know if he does
immortalize as a phoenix you know
phoenix could rise again like if he if
they pull something crazy they could use
that like metaphor and gun
i'm just saying if they want to go deep
into the whole phoenix thing that's all
no who needs a ghost when you have a
phoenix you know what i mean yeah
yeah i'll take it that's dumbledore
you know what my question is about the
more stuff
how
how are we inside
savithun's throne world if her worm is
dead
even though we killed him in the real
world
so so
he still had a worm didn't he
i can't remember that yes isn't their
connection their connection to their
worm is what gives them their ability to
create a throne world so and that's part
of why mara is down with killing the
worm because she's like oh if we kill
her worm she'll be susceptible she won't
have access to her throne world it's
like but then then we saw that we're
going to a throne world for the yeah for
expansion so like what the heck's going
to happen i i don't know i mean there's
a lot of questions
over time well because like so so the
mindbender the mindbender in forsaken
had its own throne world and that didn't
have a worm that's true
then we got there was maura yeah
she got hers from a wish right but then
like oryx found it and shattered it and
all that fun stuff yeah
yeah i don't i just don't know enough
about their own worlds
we need to bring more details
we need some clarity episodes 300 i
don't know when it's going to fall but
i'm going to look it up
somebody uh somebody get a biphone speed
dial here we need yeah
we got to get uh
violin we got to get all the way long
distance
yeah we got to get it all there so two
things i think um
from a lore standpoint because if you
actually read about like what osiris has
done because in-game they haven't really
shown him yeah they didn't say it but
talk about it yep so i believe he's
technically considered the most powerful
guardian
repeat that one more time for travis
he's considered the most powerful
guardian thank you
[Laughter]
and like doing all these super cool
things and people were like how is he in
multiple places and then we find that
out in christopher cyrus which is a
terrible expansion just have to put that
out there yes um great because they do
show that he's able to do that uh and
then the secondly to travis's point
i just remember that there's a lore book
that came out with shadow keep i believe
it's the garden of celebration book yeah
it talks about uh the garden and the two
like beings that are kind of like in
this cosmic um disagreement about
the gardening or whatever it is i'm not
super
prone to the details and basically it's
referring to the light and the darkness
like it's very clear that one of these
is what the traveler is and one of them
is what the darkness is
but this is like ancient you know
pre-existing times um
and that book makes it very clear that
they don't have morals or uh
and any real like
like what we would consider good and bad
in our it's a game to them it is a game
yeah
um
and so i think i think they're
they've done this thing in the past with
with lore books and grimoire cards where
they've sort of given us the framework
for what they're going for forward but
unless you like really deep dive into it
or watch the bite figure of the mylon
video it's kind of not like in front of
you all the time right i think that's
what they're that that book is embodying
what their ultimate goal ultimately like
darkness saga which is um
you know we're not this these are all
powerful beings
question
e for e and teddy obviously um
what the hell do you think the final
shape is
that name is so stupid i'm sorry i
haven't no i don't know i don't like the
name either i'm going to like this
because like lightfall stuck i'm like
okay i can see some dramatic literally
the fault like i get that one but i'm
like the final shape sounds like what
you would have for a project title
yes
it's not like the code name yeah it's
like it's like you know project scorpio
it's like okay project
project the final shape what i'm
hoping that changes but i'm like what's
the final shape a circle
and a triangle combined
with pointy bits on it it's called
it's amazing
actually so
so two things
if you go to sabbath right now in in
morrow's area yeah she has a triangle
over which is like the barrier that
maura put around
and then if you stand at a certain time
there's the circle circle around um and
destiny has this thing from the very
beginning they've very clearly thought
this out where the light is always
circular
because that's that's a round object is
complex and then anything darkness
related is always angular so like
motions of dark for example yes versus
modes of light modes of light or
circular most of dark are are triangles
um and they've
very very clearly defined this
throughout all of destiny's existence um
it's just not always like in your face
kind of and so i think the final shape
uh
probably refers to some merging of the
two or a reveal of what you know the
final thing is it's definitely a
metaphor it's not actually like a
physical
shape
i like the title i'll be honest really
it's just like
because i think i think there's been a
lot of like like he said all that stuff
i was gonna bring that up of like
circles versus triangles and the eternal
uh kind of
disagreement between this uh these two
like entities that are playing a game
and i think that
uh
i think it gives an opportunity for them
to elevate the storytelling because
the way i see it is the final shape is
neither of those things and we're kind
of creating our own like answer you know
what i mean
so that's just my thoughts on what's
gonna say the reason i like is because
the hans and chip final shape sounds
like something straight out of the like
lore book you know what i mean like
that's the language that they use in the
lore entries
hans actually in chat says the final
shape has been referenced in the lore
multiple times
it's the end goal of the sword logic and
the darkness to create the most
simplistic universe possible
yeah so i guess we will see
what the penultimate is referenced in a
lot of uh a lot of the lore entries well
then fine i guess i i'm just gonna
embrace the final shape then
she's gotta go ahead and uh get on board
because uh that's just what they're
gonna call it sorry sorry bungie
well we're good we're good
aside we actually have to talk about
what was in the we're an hour in and we
haven't talked about what was actually
hardly shown on screen we've like danced
around a whole bunch of stuff
uh but there's this little piece at the
beginning no no that's this show was
gonna be that no question about it we
knew what we knew what this was y'all
this is hashtag long line this is a
super long point without
would say i know where this is
longer
sister of shapes sword breaker witch
queen
which of my many names live on your lips
as you weave your story around me even
as you tread carefully through my
courtyard among those who worship the
light i have gifted would you deny me
this the virtue of this power your
answers are telling guardian ponder them
and question those who you
who promise you clarity in the face of
all you see here listen as their voice
weight waivers
as you lift
and as you lift your new steel from the
heart of the forge ask yourself what
force wields you i await you guardian
step into my throne world and behold the
truth that's just the little body text
that they have on the start of the witch
queen page sounds really cool and also
just shout out to the writing team
killing it all the time just setting
everything up
um so we got the big cinematic to open
this thing up
and i think everybody's jaw was probably
on the floor they had to go pick it up
afterwards with everything that we saw
probably the biggest mind-blown thing
was
first
probably the lucent brood
so sabathune has gifted her soldiers
with the power of the light as the night
you struck down rises from the dead for
the second time a feeling of betrayal
washes over you and you can't help but
wonder when the light offers no shelter
no solace where will you turn and we
literally get to see hive
risen by
hive ghosts from her little pool that
they're all floating in
one is like a sentinel hive knight where
he's chunking a shield and just like
destroying guardians there's like an ark
it looks like a it i thought it smashed
but i thought it was also a floating
wizard so i'm not sure about the arc one
and then of course there's like the
acolyte who does the throwing knives
i was and i was just like when you guys
saw the fact that the hive are getting
light powers
thoughts whoever wants to go first just
dive in
cog the disrespect
it was just like it was so good but i
was just like and i hate it was the way
she said it too she
look at your truth that look at you now
you thought you was this you know
without blemish you
we in our own minds think we're this
purity right it almost reminds me a
little bit of um
when myth racks reveal to how like state
14 is looked at by the fallen you know
say like you're the hero of your own
story
but it's just curious to be about
perspective
yes
it's curious to me that's why i cannot
wait to see
how this acquisition of the light
happens for her for sabbath
because you know like travis said if
it's something that is given if the
travel like bestows it like that is a
slap in the face to all we currently
believe because we think we're the
heroes in our son we we're the pure like
no so that that will be very interesting
to me you know how that is but to your
question overall
yes amazing amazing to see how i've
gotti it's that great twist and last
point i'm saying i'll give it to you
trav was i love the fact that not only
do you gotta kill them
you actually have to finish the goal
that's funny that's i was like finish
him
now the question for y'all yeah do you
think
when we fight harv hive guarding the
loose and blue if you don't kill the
coast can they be rest
probably oh for sure oh yeah it's like a
zombie you gotta like you know burn them
or a couple like shoot them in the like
i think the mechanic
i hope you can shoot it because you have
to run up and crush it with your hand
every time that's right you have to do a
finishing move on those guys there
there's a lore behind this that you have
to kill a ghost you can't kill a ghost
with normal bullets it has to be
paracausal bullets and that's how kade
goes out about that sniper uses one of
those para causal bullets so like are
the rules different for hive uh
guardians or can guardian kill another
guardian like is this like a vampire
thing or what is the highlander what is
it one of those ones where they can only
be one highlander
they can only be killed by their own
kind or whatever one of those things uh
i just have a lot of questions about the
lore there but cog what i was gonna say
is what's up to the point of how they
get the light
my theory is that like
the traveler
doesn't view us as giving us the light
as a gift to us he's turning us into
weapons that he gets so it's like a
selfish thing like he'll give the light
to anybody because it's not like he it's
not like he's giving you a weapon it's
you're the weapon and you're defending
it right so he's recruiting you into his
army and it's it's self-indulgent it's
him
gaining the power and you're the weapon
okay and so i think that the hive just
become like another weapon that the
traveler can then wield against its
enemies and then the questions i have
are like why are we fighting the hive
then if they're guardians too shouldn't
we be on the same technically we're on
the same team yeah shouldn't shouldn't
it be like the uh the like is the ending
of the witch queen going to be that we a
lot a liar
that's where i'm going because i'm like
technically we are all
unless which i don't think is happening
guardians are going to get stripped like
the fallen do i don't anticipate that
happening right not first i have a game
to play no exactly
vanilla destiny too
right so if we're guardians
and their guardians
why are we fighting
i think the answer is because of sabbath
so if we cut off the head then it it
lets the rest of the hive become our
allies potentially but it's like if
they're freed from the worms and they
use the light and they don't have
sabbath in kind of pulling their strings
and making them uh do things that we
disagree with like i could see a path
where we become allies with them because
i just wouldn't be surprised at this
point we're becoming allies with every
other faction except the vex who i guess
are probably uh
beyond saving maybe not though they can
be reprogrammed that happens in the
movies
teddy i don't know so so two things um i
know that they've mentioned recently
uh that pair causal bullets have to kill
ghosts but uh the shot of the opening
for christos cyrus segura gets shot by
like a normal goblin or minotaur or
something
um
and she doesn't function and then you
have to do that dumb mission on the edz
but she wasn't dead though she was just
kind of like knocked out
yeah yeah but we had to like re-embody
her
essence or something with that yeah
some weirdness yeah i just i just bring
that up because you got controls a few
places that's okay yeah yeah um
so
a point to what you said cog about uh
the line that she has in the trailer i
think ultimately at the end of the
season it's probably going to reveal
that she
tricks us in some way
to get the light like yes i don't think
i don't think the traveler's going to
give it to her willingly that's how i
feel that's how i feel too on some level
and
if you actually look at the trailer like
if you kind of freeze frame a lot of the
gameplay that they're showing uh we're
fighting scorn more than we're fighting
uh
um actually
that could just be a trailer thing but a
lot of the places they're showing where
we're fighting scorn appear to be in the
throne world
uh which i just i thought that was
interesting because the scorn have kind
of been this like
they kind of exist but they're not
really
up until presage they weren't really
used for anything recent right and then
pressure they explain why that has
happened and it you know makes sense
um
but
like there's it's a lot of questions man
there's a lot going on that uh yeah i
want them to explain i also have a
question about
the the ghosts so if if if you become a
guardian and you get ghosts your ghosts
look like you so then are humans robots
what like why are our ghosts robotic and
the hive ours come from the traveler and
i would say the ghosts that we're seeing
now are coming from like a creation of
sabathun so it's more i would say the
ghost and this is pure speculation out
of my butt yeah but it seems like
because do we know what the fallen
ghosts look like i honestly couldn't
tell you they look like so the fallen
never actually got the light they just
got the the benefit of oh you're right
you're right you're right that created
you know they created their golden age
right right which is what happened when
the traveler would go places the
traveler would release the ghosts as a
final stand against the darkness that's
right that's what stopped the stop the
collapse and then made the traveler go
into hibernation and then when gaul
restrained the traveler that's when it
became undormant
uh
again and became active which also
related to the pyramids
yeah i just i don't know why they go i'm
curious to see how they explain why the
ghosts look like take that yeah you're
concerned the form that it's taken out
yeah some of the some of the human
uh
ghosts like like osiris ghost doesn't
look like anyone else's
you know the same like but they all look
like robots yeah i still want to know
what's up they don't they don't resemble
humans like it's like what if we had
like fleshy
human ghosts are we ever gonna get the
logic of the hive the lc fish by the way
what's up with the fish oh yeah
chelsea yeah so i mean
these ghosts was that a ghost yeah it's
not a ghost they did state that but we
won't be able to get those
maybe ever
so she she comes this version of lc
comes from a reality that the light is
gone and that's kind of their
like their ghost but it doesn't give her
light powers
as far as we know right she doesn't have
light powers she has some powers but
it's not light
because she does like the the stasis
slam yeah in that in that cinematic
where they're doing that
powers yeah but it's right because in
her reality they used the darkness
that's right right corrupted them yeah
they all died or something yeah and then
we were like yeah that's fine let's use
the darkness that sounds great
doesn't like it so what so um yes we
have new hive to fight sorry we fell
down another rabbit hole no that's this
whole thing's going to be rabbit hole
after rabbit hole after rabbit hole so
hope you guys are just enjoying your
ears being filled with the sounds of our
wonderful voices for god knows how long
um
next piece her throne world is has a
very
two distinct pieces to it and this is
kind of what we're tying into very old
leaks one is her
little her throne castle her situation
like all glorious and looks like it
looks like the shadow keep done in white
yes like the red castle that's about
white it's about my shadow keep showing
that's what it reminded me of yeah
uh and then you've got the other side
which is like a swamp so you've got this
huge juxtaposition between
like this dark gloomy greenish swamp and
this white and red like city that she's
in and this is her throne world and from
a distant picture it looks like the
whole thing's in this big giant tub from
far away yeah like a bowl yeah i was
like so there's the bowl there then this
is on the outside i can't quite figure
out where everything's at but i wanted
to get you guys um
don't forget about the pyramid ship
that's that's where they should monitor
the raid that's sitting over in the
swamp apparently
yep and that one that's where the raid
so
which apparently is not a real pyramid
because it's in her throne world
that's great that's where the raid will
take place in the pyramid ships yes she
pulled the pyramid into her throne world
but yeah it's definitely where the raid
is taking place
yeah well they said that they confirmed
that yeah they say that it's on the page
for the dlc so we have a pyramid ship in
the swamp outside of her crazy either
bowl or castle or whatever
realm that she's got built and this is
her entire throne world
do you guys like the looks of the
environment are you kind of blown away
excited is it does it live up to what
you might have thought it could have
been also i'm gonna say it now the big
rumored leaks about old chicago i feel
like they're like half of the area
because of the swamp like they have like
you know trees and forests and swampy
areas like i think that's literally half
of the area and then now they've gone
into where this story went as opposed to
chicago they kind of turned it into that
i think but my thoughts aside guys
yeah so there was uh
there was yesterday today somebody
already pointed out that this like like
og destiny concept art
for the deep stone crypt actually looks
really similar to the like fortress
uh thing that she's using there um and
then if we want to kind of dive into the
the paceman leak for a second one second
um shout out to jamie in tat chat oh we
just basically said green man gaming is
twenty percent off all which win content
so if you're looking for the expansion
you actually get it off but shout out to
jamie thank you for the super chat two
bucks hello
i did actually say that i forgot about
it anyway back to where you are
so spoilers for a second are potential
spoilers i guess the paceman link
mentions um
that originally the destination for this
was going to be a moon of saturn i can't
remember the name and it was supposed to
be the biggest destination they were
going to build but they scrapped it
um in favor of this destination
um
so i still think of chicago is coming
because i think that was one of the
original places they built for whatever
destiny one was supposed to be and
they've just shelved it for a long time
and the reason i say that is in one of
the really early vidocs before the game
came out there's about three or four
seconds of footage where they're on this
hill with a bunch of trees overlooking a
city
um and i believe that's that's chicago
that's never been used it's not in the
game anywhere um obviously justice i
can't imagine them having two swamp
locations in the game teddy also you've
already got edc and cosmodrome i don't
think they need any more on earth either
i guess i don't know i think
i think it's going to be a city like
it's going to be more city
versus swamp
okay if they ever do this you know it's
possible they don't
trev were you happy with my biggest
yeah my biggest disappointment i'll
start with the stuff that makes me sad
which is that it doesn't look like we're
gonna get the old chicago vibe i was
hoping for which is like us fighting
giant frogs and uh kind of like the
weird wildlife like a weird western uh
sort of vibe uh it looks like instead
that's just going like straight fantasy
you know there's a
old swamp leading to a literal witch's
uh castle which is like you know the
pencil and grenade adventure cliche yeah
it's like it's like that which i'm down
with i like the fact that it's not in
it's not a real location like you guys
said it looks like it's in a bowl so
like who knows how it'll show up on the
director it could just be you know like
a logo or whatever but it could be it's
a pocket reality so it doesn't really
need to physically be anywhere which i
kind of like and i also like that we can
deal with some of like the meta
metaphorical stuff right like it's like
uh we can see like a monster that
doesn't have to physically exist which
means that if bungie does it right they
can have a lot of fun with different
types of mobs that we fight uh we could
fight a literal dragon you know like
like uh not not just the one that we
fought in the the raid either
i don't think they will though i just i
don't think we're gonna get new mobs i
think we're gonna just get hive that
have uh different abilities uh and maybe
some taken would be my hope but uh i it
doesn't look like we're gonna be
introduced to any like crazy new
factions or any any new uh types of
monsters
at least that they've shown yet and i
think they're holding a lot off i still
think vapor is coming with this
expansion i just think that they're not
talking about are you talking about
actually they confirmed that today
yeah yeah so joe blackman did an
interview on twitch gaming and uh
there is a new subclass coming just not
with witchcraft
not in year five
subclass or power type damage type power
type yeah they covered it all it's not
coming they said it is worth being
worked on i'm guessing what happened
with that is they worked on stasis
releases
i think they mentioned it in the 12th
too they mentioned it too late they
talked about like void 3.0 in there
which we'll get 3.0 whenever we get
there but yeah um
yeah they did mention that it is it is
something they're working on but i think
with as much work as they've had to do
to try and
get stasis where it is
i don't think they were ready to do that
all over again
balance light which we'll get to what's
happening with those
yep yeah there is no green subclass
coming that has been confirmed it is not
in there so shout out to kuje and his
corruption you can sit on that video for
like a year
yeah no doubt but i'll make it quick
because i know it's a long one um i like
it i love the visual representation of
the uh
the throne world i i thought it looked
really majestic it would to me it was
just like you know the clean version of
shadow keep
you know saying just you know they
brushed the walls down it's all pristine
everything got about everything got
power washed they power washed
simulators
and i still like her little you know
angular toilet bowl could you know the
thing that she's got going on and i
think it fits i i just like everything
very high fantasy yes very high fantasy
and it's a it's a it's an elegance to it
that i like too because it's dark but
it's also like that female elegant part
to it that i like so somebody mentioned
one piece with regards to the picture
the trailer of her
and it's the mention of her the line
between the light and dark is so thin
and like the right side of the screen is
very light shining over here and it's
dark on the other side and she's walking
down the water in between them
and i was just like they're more
flirting with like as bright as her city
is again it's this back and forth of
light and dark that they keep toying
with yeah when you look at the picture
and i see the it now she's got like the
her like you know front office on the
front of the toilet bowl and then down
below you've got the bridge and kind of
the lower city but it does if fantasy is
probably the perfect way to describe
that i would say like very very high
fantasy
and they just basically describe it a
twisted wonderland of corruption in
splendor literally light and dark in the
words there sabathan's throne world
plays host to a fragile balance of
terrifying power from the foundation of
her glistening palace to the gnarling
roots in the swamp all that she hides
can be found here seek the truth and
learn that in this place mystery makes
its home in both the darkness and the
light
verbatim then so yeah
um
it's gonna be cool i will be curious how
big it is how much exploration how many
secrets i think is the biggest thing i'm
looking forward to because they showed
you know what looks like little
platforms appearing i think this is
going to be that dreadnought type moment
yeah yeah
not like on an actual ship but i think
the way there were secrets hidden things
all the random little stuff we found
over time on that ship i think are going
to be the same way this throne world
with all the differences maybe abilities
where you can see different things all
of what we're going to get in there they
can do it almost there they want in that
throne world because as you guys said
it's like a pocket reality so there's a
whole lot of things that they don't have
to kind of abide by
relatively normal in this game
um
so that obviously was slightly larger
speaking of high fantasy
yes they're also giving us a new weapon
type that is extremely high fantasy oh
yeah you're getting right to where i was
going so we got a new that's a segway
and a half thank you sir um so we've got
two things we've got the
relic which is where we're going to be
doing weapon crafting which when i heard
those words i thought they were kidding
for a second
and then also we have a brand new weapon
type that is
a powerful melee weapon in first person
can fire projectiles and deploy an
energy shield this is like the
the weapon it's called a glaive and it's
i mean it is a glaive but it looks like
a pole arm with a much longer sword on
it
so
who is when it comes to weapon crafting
from me they say master the new weapon
crafting system and create custom
weaponry with unique custom combinations
of mods shaders and advanced stat pools
when fighting a god leave nothing on the
table and they would they mentioned in
the trailer and i haven't gone back to
watch that thing like seven times yet to
really get it all
but i would definitely say like the idea
of crafting weapons
whether it's trying to get what travis
was for trials like hey i want to pick
the perks on my weapon
and they also mentioned like leveling up
your weapon as you work through it i'm
kind of curious how all of the
functionality is going to work but the
idea of
being able to have a little more direct
path with work in a game like this is
what an rpg typically would have so the
fact that we're finally getting into
crafting going after building materials
putting it together how you want to make
it have different play styles and be
like hey you make a cool one but i need
to go make another one
you know there's certain resources that
are going to be limited so certain
things are going to be harder to do you
may get this one shot at one but you
might be able to make six of the other
weapon crafting is always a really cool
thing done right so i'm really hoping
obviously they've uh you know they're
gonna think it through but also it's
bungee i feel like they're gonna roll
out a system and people are gonna be
like hey here's all these things but
this one thing's not right
but it's probably gonna be too far along
in development to have it quite fixed
and then we'll get that changed like
three to six months later but overall
i'm pretty hyped the glaive i will say
since i've let you guys all go first i'm
getting my pieces down get your balls
off baby get your boss for the glaive
itself the projectile seems cool i don't
know if i saw the shield i didn't see as
much of the combat and i watched it once
or twice
i don't know if the animations just
didn't quite seem right in the moment
but the animation of like it didn't seem
like the sword's cool like a lot of the
animations in this game are like second
to none because they feel
right for what you're doing
watching it on screen didn't quite feel
right from what i saw that's just me i
like the idea of the weapon but from
what i saw it didn't quite
like the little first person yeah i was
like probably poke you with a spear and
it just doesn't that doesn't quite feel
right at least they didn't so i'll be
curious they handle things like bows i
never thought were going to be done well
both feel very good
yeah because in this game it's like it's
guns bows feel really good so i do have
faith that they will get it right but
again it just it looked weird on screen
to me
yeah my pre-alpha they didn't have the
caveat with the pre-alpha yeah it's like
animations i know it will get tweaked
and they master those things as well but
so the the shooting sounds straight up
the shotgun sound sorry
yeah really yeah i tend to just
not question i give i give bun i don't
often give bungie the benefit of the
doubt but when it comes to weapon design
yeah i gotta hand it to him so i just
sort of i'm like i'm sure it'll feel
fine yeah my question is
what what is the projectile like is it a
shotgun blast because then i don't
really understand
what the need is for the melee part
because the shotgun blast is always
gonna
either be better or you could just use a
shotgun if that was your goal right well
maybe it's something that your questions
about you build towards to get the the
blast you don't say like i don't know
but why do you need the blast if you're
mailing someone you know what i mean
like if you're gonna hit them with a
sword
or vice versa like if you have to melee
to get the blast and then blast them why
why wouldn't you just use a regular
shotgun i guess i'm thinking about it on
a pvp mic
yeah i'm like okay i'm like where's he
going with this okay i got you know what
i mean like like if i was attacking
someone with a grave in pv pve a glaive
or sorry pvp i just can't see the
advantage strategically i really am just
thinking about it from people no i'm
standing in point probably understanding
point yeah it's gonna be interesting to
see how they get at the beginning but to
ease point i actually did
think how he thought scared anything
yeah it didn't look clean but i was like
i'm gonna get you a pass pre-alpha
we know when they get busy how they do
with weapons like you said i ain't even
concerned too much in the least just let
them cook and do what they do with
weapons i i thought weapon crafting was
the biggest announce we got yeah the
entire show that was mostly because like
teddy said like teddy and i sort of were
spoiled by a lot of the leaks so like a
lot of that was covered in the paceman
but i don't think weapon weapon crafting
was so that was like a huge surprise to
me when i heard that i was like whoa
that's wild
it was but not in detail they they
actually went into detail um a lot more
than yeah
yeah they said it's gonna be for all i
was just gonna say it's gonna be for all
i didn't clarify all witch queen weapons
and season 16 weapons and so like that's
a pretty decent pool to start and
they're so they're going to expand both
older and newer as time progresses so
starting relatively small but it's going
to be a system that grows substantially
yes so when they specifically every when
we watched the whole thing before the
podcast when they specifically said
uh and other weapons will come later
they showed two of the um serif weapons
from season of the worthy they showed
the saw and uh yes i can't remember the
other one so basically the these guns
that have now been phased out of the
world loop pool will probably end up
being dropped there and also war mine
cells obviously now are here to stay
because they've kind of rained them in a
little bit yeah
a lot of it but over overall uh i think
the
the new weapon type is their answer to
people wanting swords in the special
slot uh
for the longest time people have been
asking for that that's been like a
common request that's coming up yeah
up until recently when the swords got
reworked and actually became usable
and i think this is kind of their
solution to that um that ask uh
i also think it's really important to
note that they kept it in first person
like yeah because they don't want three
peaking anymore
yeah and they get to the track section
when they announced when they announced
that way back they were gonna get rid of
three people they said any future
uh weapons will not be third person
as a result of this and if they are
we'll you know we'll figure out a way so
you can't use it in pvp in pvp
but then also it's a cool twist right
like it's a melee weapon
in first person which is i think
something that you don't see
uh often in a first person shooter nope
no usually usually
oh halo yeah no yeah the gravity hammer
in a couple of the shots of the footage
they do show uh
blocking
um
they do show that blocking i think
that's cool it's also important to know
this is a special weapon yes yes
energy slot right that makes it yeah
that makes it
extra special no pun intended uh because
of how compact that spot is and they've
addressed that they've talked about that
too that the energy slot is way too
overcrowded in the heavy slot too which
is why stasis weapons are in the primary
slot now right
uh crafting overall big plus because uh
diablo has the system and as long as
they kind of get it right or it doesn't
cost too much and my time investment is
not crazy that's the one
that's the biggest a-okay because if
they make it where it's like like
vanilla d one right
i'm worried that this is just a big
replacement for moats of light and like
leveling up your weapon to unlocking
stuff and i would just be pissed but it
but to be to their credit they didn't
talk about it like that in the show they
said as like a way for you to like focus
farm for specific roles and stuff which
that's very different from what the d1
they also did make it a point twice to
say that uh you you can craft as you
play uh yeah those were the exact words
but that's essentially what they were
hinting at which is you just play the
game and you'll craft a weapon and you
kind of do it passively in the
background so as long as i can kind of
the objectives aren't too specific then
i'm i'm totally fine diablo does this
almost perfectly like if they just watch
they're going to introduce weapon weave
that's how you craft as you go
yeah
we go get a new jobs
yup you're going to have four new
currencies one with you
unlock over time automatically by
playing one that you have to get through
bounties i'm hoping they learned a
little training at a retail store
physically
you gotta go get the best buy warranty
on your weapons
that was like the biggest thing for me i
could see them doing that man
do not underestimate bungie when it
comes to botching systems and adding
unnecessary currencies and finding ways
to make you pay money yeah they'll be
like oh you can you can earn these in
the game you can farm them or you could
pay to get the exact revenue well
straight up be a mobile game at that
point that would be yeah this weapon
hey it already is a mobile game if you
play on xcloud or stadium you're
ridiculous
i'm with you from the from the obsession
of universe they've ever reversed
they've drawn a pretty clear line it's
cosmetic
it's cosmetic only it's not gonna affect
gameplay they they kind of sort of
skirted the line a little bit in early
destiny 2
um yeah up until shadow keep with with
ghosts and um also armor had stats on it
but the armor always had bad stats from
yeah
that was on purpose
um
that's kind of as close as they've gone
but to their credit i think they've done
a good job the grind aspect of things
like transmog i think is terrible though
it is a little better this season with
the change i actually did a couple and
it's
it's not it's not as bad yeah it's not
bad
yeah like yeah my biggest thing about
crafting is i want the system to be
enjoyable
like as you said they can mess up a
system they can mess up currency the
time investment all of those things can
be done poorly or done well so it's like
i wanna that's a system as it is so
important to any deep rpg like a living
world that we're going to have i
understand there's going to be some time
to it but yeah as you said don't make it
awful a cool thing i did read
there are going to be ex class exotic
exclusives yes back to that baby like
hunters
get their own type of exotic glaze which
i'm really excited to see that that's
going to be a thing i'm hoping it's not
just like swords where it's like here
you get one exotic sword per subclass
and there's no other glaze
i don't know if that's how it's just
gonna be like one for each or if there's
actually gonna be a legendary version or
anything of that nature
never because they seem to always
introduce stuff and be like here's your
one we'll just do it and that's it but
we'll see did they say the glaive they
didn't do that
true
they didn't say specifically glaive was
exotic but they are exclusive they're
class exotic exclusives right so i know
there are those i just don't know if
they're going to do it like they did
swords in destiny 1 or it's like you
have three exotics and that's it
it's kind of the type of weapon where
the only way you can make different ones
is if it if it has a cool ability when
you shoot it or block or something like
that otherwise you only need one um i
mean this is kind of the problem that
bows have currently
um yeah basically the only difference
between the bows is how fast you can
draw but that can be compensated for
with certain perks yep and every bow
needs aside from exotics needs archer's
tempo on it to actually be like yeah
usable yep so it's really it's really
hard to
differentiate the bodies
from each other aside from the draw yeah
i mean the exotic bows are fun but yeah
it's like you have a basic glaive or you
have glasses that like shoot fireworks
out of the end so just see how they do
it
uh next piece we have solve the
mysteries they say pierce the line a
sprawling web of evidence
uh lies before you shadows nip at your
heels as you retreat into the light only
to find the enemy waiting bolstered by a
power it does not deserve face the witch
queens loosen brood and solve the riddle
at the heart of her deceit so we've got
a new six player match made activity
this is conflict eternal i don't doubt
that's actually the name
um
basically an ongoing struggle for the
balance to be maintained in her throne
world and then so we have one six player
matchmaking activity confirmed and then
we also have the new raid among the
swans of sabathun's throne world lies a
sunken pyramid alongside your fire team
venture inward and confront the ancient
danger imprisoned within
which makes me think
sabathan's not the raid boss
definitely not yeah which you should be
happy i don't know i am i'm actually
like okay which makes me think that she
hopefully has some ongoing story arc
discussion
if she dies in the campaign i'm not
gonna be thrilled he's dying in the
campaign don't tell me that i can
guarantee you why are you saying that to
you
why do you say that because
on one hand they're doing something that
they've never done before and i think
they should be applauded for it which is
that they are introducing a villain
before we kill her we're gonna have six
months of hanging out with sabbath
before we actually do the game we're
gonna get like 10 weeks but
ten weeks ten weeks of this season's
story of this season
but but you know they'll do something
closer to the witch queen i i feel
they'll have like an epilogue right
before the witchcraft an epilogue like
six months after we've already done all
the stuff we do with her
so i think there will be that
she must have some involvement in the
30th anniversary maybe we'll just forget
about her but i feel like if she's in
the background doing stuff there has to
be like some sort of mention and there
might also be surprise stuff we don't
know
the point is it's not hey gall is here
you're going to know him for a couple
hours before he's dead we're gonna know
her have known her for six months and
also now know that she's been
responsible for the last year of destiny
essentially
so we have a relationship with her going
into it i just don't think there's a way
she survives the
expansion i don't know i don't i don't
see i don't see a possible path toward
it the only
evidence that she might survive it
is that we're still going to get to hang
out in her throne world but
when it comes to the consistency of
locations i would not
bank on bungie because you know the
dreaming city has been the way it is for
like an extra year on top of it look at
that i'm spreading it sorry montes
um
but uh
yeah i just i just don't i just don't
think she's gonna survive am i crazy for
thinking that i mean
i would say previously with gaul and
other things we've seen raid or oryx at
least made it to a raid
so he got a little longer life i would
say and if she's not in the raid as big
as she is potentially even in chat's
been joking about like
at some point we theoretically now have
fallen allies we have cabal allies would
it be possible for us to have hive
allies she seems like the one because
what we learned from season of the lost
were deworming sabathune we're obviously
seeing
we're getting that you know hunger away
and all of these things are kind of
coming to a point where she
she is a giant trickster and we know
that she's not trustworthy but on the
other side we're getting to a point
where it's possible or she isn't going
to be completely against us to what
level i have no idea but i think it's
more possible that way we're setting her
up at least this time
that she could stay around that's just
me
ooga that's all i have to say you know
normally i would go travis but i would e
i would e i think
i think this is gonna twist i'm
surprised you say that travis because
you literally
said what you said about her with the
light and and to me her having the light
changes things
it changes the dynamics so now i got you
teddy uh so now i'm like
she
see new red yeah dude i'm with new rad
here see we meet you back on point like
to me she's scared of the darkness yeah
the darkness is still the overarching
thing
so at the end of the day she's putting
herself in the best position possible
right so that that's how i look at it
it's like survival through deception
so i look at it like yo at the end of
the day
we may not like it but we're gonna have
to deal with her and i still say she's
around and the fact that i'm finding out
that now why are we killing all of our
guardians then
it's a good question if there was ever
time to if there was a time to ally with
her it was it would be right now and
especially after she gets the light but
if we're going into the witch queen with
a conflict with her i just don't see
that i agree that the hive could end up
being a rally but i think sabbath has to
be dead before that can happen so are we
theoretically going to pair up with
zebra because we can't we cannot trust
her right and i think that the hive join
us as like a mob not with sabbath at the
head because we would just never be able
to
how do you trust the how do you trust
her you have to you have to like
somebody else
is is
mythrax is a trustworthy guy for
everything else that he is but like but
she got the light bro it changes things
that's the key to what i was gonna say
does it change we'll have like a power
vacuum though if we eliminate her you
leave zebra wrath who's already shown to
be
trying to invade us for some reason and
she's trying and i don't know what her
and zevarat's deal is between the two
sisters right now but if we're gonna
side with i think zevu's dead before
this happens personally
again i have no idea but it's
and there is there is no power vacuum if
you kill sabbath because who are the
hive gonna report to the traveler just
like we do report they already have
their replacement for sabbath yeah but
we don't know if the guardian if the
hive guardians
if she steals the light somehow and
she's able to imbue it to them
again i don't know but it's like it
depends on how they are risen is it from
her power that she's somehow like
acquired or something or is it on the
other side where are they actually of
the traveler or are they of her and her
throat is this all in her little pocket
reality and none of this crap matters
anyway nobody i don't really know but
i'm still wondering
about that like she may be able to do
things in her throne world that are
pretty much non-existent anywhere else
you do it
teddy he even wait i did reference it as
a wonderland maybe this is all like
wizard of oz it's just a dream at the
years and you all had the light
and
end
of
i'm down with doing teddy stones ready
all right here's my here's my throat in
theory let's go so
the events are forsaken specifically
happen and take place so that sabbath
can create this loop that happens
forever in which her her worm is fed yep
and through the success of that plan
she's been able to do everything else
uh to basically
without having to deal with the worm
problem that all the hive gods suffer
from but you know we we kill
duel incarnate every
week or every three weeks if they're
following the cursed cycle and that
feeds her worm and the curse precisely
and that's the wish she made right at
the at the end
so since then saturn's been scheming and
doing all these things and to your point
i think that she realizes that the
darkness is the ultimate enemy and she's
the ally with us but in order to do that
she has to convince us that
she's not actually tricking us
that this is something that they need to
survive and the reason i say this is
this entire year every season is
specifically focused on aside from
season of the hunt which is zevo wrath
focus and hive
is focused on a a race that has been an
enemy of ours so the cabal the fallen
and now
that's where i was going
i don't think we'll ever align with the
vex because the vex are just this
autonomous hive mind of robots that only
have one goal which is to transform and
and and
hack the system you can do you do that
with a software piece just place the
system right back the planet
uh we just changed their core uh their
core desire by uh turning a one into a
zero
this this season's high focus right and
so what we've seen the last two seasons
is we ultimately end up allying allying
this thing that we've we've been
fighting for seven years like dude you
know how many cabal i slayed
or the fallen they talk about saint
fourteen i'm the real clarify
i'm not denying that we ally with the
hive i'm denying that we all i was
sabathoon and the hive well so i i think
i think over the course of the season
she will slowly convince us that we do
need to ally with her but then she will
end up tricking us which is how she gets
the light and that's why we're still
fighting them uh
in the witch queen
um
but her goal and she's she's said this
her goal is
to to help fight the darkness and at the
same time she's avoiding zuba wrath who
wants to kill her for some i'm assuming
i don't think we know why
um
and and so there's a sort of this
conflict of interest uh that we have and
that's why maura realizes that that's um
we need to do this and that's why if you
listen to actually the radio
transmission in the helm from her and i
cora i didn't get a chance to listen to
it yet they go back and forth a little i
don't spoil it too much
basically she's like i'm trying to save
morris saying i'm trying to save you all
and i cora's getting all like pissy and
upset about it um she's like because
that car is like you're getting tricked
you're getting played right right yeah
she's like you're gonna end up getting
us all killed and more like no i'm
trying to save all of you uh and we
obviously know that that she has this
like grand plan right because she she
schemed this whole thing where oryx is
going to kill her and she'd come back
and get her thrown world and all this
like crazy like she obviously is like at
sabbath level of
of um
knowledge or what's the over under on
her not surviving season of the lost
because i think it's pretty high mara
mara
she has to survive she's too big
they want to bring the voice actor back
for one season
because she hasn't she hasn't had any
lines uh since i like i like that
business thought i like the business
plan
well they did that with osiris
this is that season though right
i don't think you can kill mara saw
between her connection
and like she's
this weird link between so many
different pieces between crow now a
savathun and then her realm that she's
she's got too many connections to this
whole universe of hive and throne worlds
and everything else i don't think you
bring her in
you know have everybody drool over here
in the first place and then like i don't
think you can get rid of that quickly
think about the business side just
simply simplify it simplify it like
teddy said at esa trap
from the business side you just hide
what's her name deborah some you hired
uh an actress to play sabbath dude that
you're not killing that in the first
reign and we're never seeing that again
i'm talking about mara
i always talk about more i'm talking
about myself i don't think
is going to survive season the lost i
think she's no no i'm saying she will
i'm saying she will because they they
wouldn't bring the voice actor back for
one season to kill her off the only time
they've done this is with lakshmi last
season they brought they brought the
voice actor back so she could die off in
one season i thought that was kind of
like oh okay so that's a precedent
yeah but that's one time versus every
other time where they where they've
brought okay they got us for christmas
the guy didn't have any lines
uh they brought back um
aldrin aldrin only talked in destiny one
briefly and and forsaken and they
brought him back for an entire year like
i just i think maura is like lakshmi's a
minor character i think mario's too big
of a character to bring back for one
season and be like all right let's just
kill her um i'm just saying when it
comes to killing off big characters they
never shied away they killed cage
same thing with sabathune i don't i
think sabaton will die and then be
reborn and that's how she gets the light
and i think that's ultimately her goal
but again i don't think you get this new
voice actress to to play the voice for
one or two seasons and then be like all
right peace out uh
such a big character like lakshmi's a
minor character
um
this is like you know this is up there
with this it's a
a little too hard i feel like there's a
good chance that she's she's she's doing
exactly what lakshmi did right like
thinking that she can outsmart powers
that she can't possibly uh hope to go to
toe-to-toe with and i could just see
sabathune just kind of she thinks that
she's about to kill sabathon right like
mara's like oh yeah if we get rid of her
worm we're gonna totally have her back
against the wall we already know that's
nice we already know that's not gonna
work right i saw the trailer right so i
i'm just saying i could see her pulling
a lakshmi where it ends up with her
dying off screen on a radio transmission
not i'm joking she'll definitely die on
screen she'll definitely die on screen
if she dies but i could just see that
happening where she's like all right now
we've got sabbath and seven's gonna be
like uh uh uh you know like you didn't
sing the message but you you you
activated my trap card situation mm-hmm
so okay no
it's a cool theory it's a cool thing i
don't it's not out the realm of a
possibility i i could see a scenario of
of that happening i mean
we got to see how this play out but we
clearly know whatever bar is playing
ain't working coming for next season oh
for sure
she's screwing up yeah
or that's all part of her plan just like
with orcs
she she's like the palpatine
of of the destination but i mean like
you we literally had like the drifter
and she's like one of the images
floating in the clouds like the idea of
what she's been
she's been this like force
you know out in the universe somewhere
and she's i still think she's too big of
a force like as sabathun is as much of a
trickster thinker all of the however you
want to describe those i think marasov
is deep enough and has enough foresight
to
[Music]
know who she's messing with
she's very aware of who she's dealing
with and i think
now granted yeah something gets us to
her throne world i don't know what that
is but i don't think it's enough to kill
mara that's the thing
there may be something that goes on
she's she's playing like a rookie right
now that's all i'll say
but yeah
right and what we've seen so far yeah
anyway
but she literally was like i know this
is not a good she literally states like
i know this is not a good like situation
to be in but i still think it's the best
way for us to get what we like she knows
it's not a good thing to have savithun
where she is and even be working with
her and she's like she's gonna like
sabotage us the first chance she gets
she flat says that she's like i'm not
ignorant to it right like i think she's
aware that yeah she is aware she's
always she did say that so maybe she
just doesn't care if if the hive get the
light because it also hurts guardians
who she's not a guardian she doesn't she
doesn't care about us i don't know maybe
maybe she's the daughter of a
mara is suss as always
hey can make new videos it's uh
tomorrow's tomorrow watch what i got i
got a cup yeah i gotta come fall boy uh
wilhelm scream we need you to come to
the front of the conversation with with
his
hair brain theory i had to keep hearing
every last word this man has been on
every party chat i mean that marisol is
definitely savithoon can we officially
put this one debate that seems like yeah
yeah i think we're good yes i love you i
love you i like you scream i love you
unless
unless
because what if she is sabothune
wouldn't the best cover ever be like oh
look i found osiris he was actually
savithoon not me but you know what we
should do is we should help sabathune
out and kill her worm for her i know
that it sounds stupid and should
probably betray us but it's really our
best option right now like if you were
sabothune saying that it would be
brilliant but that's
conspiracy theories it's impossible to
disprove them right like you can just
come up with an alternative
with something to keep it yeah yeah so
right technically he's still in the mix
he's screaming my bad you're still in
the mix
you're still in the mix scream my bad my
bad my bad you're right well as for
which queen if there's been anything
else i've kind of forgotten i'm going to
go through basically what's included
with witch queen now when we buy it and
touch on a couple other pieces
so deluxe edition is kind of the one
that covers most of it i'll get to the
30th here in a second um not a second
probably another half an hour but who
knows how long that takes
so the deluxe edition has a new campaign
and this is actually something i hadn't
even mentioned yet
the campaign is
they mention the campaign as being on a
level of
pressage
of the exotic quests
and also with higher difficulty options
that go back forward so they it sounds
like they're making this
like the destiny campaign compared to
anything else what do you guys think of
how they've worded it so far do you
think like my thought on it's wrong do
you think this is gonna be like the
ultimate campaign what do you guys think
trav
i mean according to their own
statements that we're not getting a
expansion like forsaken and i think
we're definitely not getting a second
location like we did with forsaken um
i actually was expecting there to be
like in old chicago and then the throne
world was like the end game location but
i i think that's pretty clearly like not
gonna happen so yeah
uh
yeah i don't think it's gonna be i think
what they might end up doing is
making the campaign take longer to get
through kind of like destiny 1 or
destiny 2 vanilla right where there's
like those checkpoints where you have to
grind in between so i think they might
space the cama campaign out to make it
longer but i don't think it's going to
be as like massive and like packed with
stuff and i think there'll be secrets
throughout the world and i think it'll i
think it'll probably be closer to taking
care which that's not bad at all but i
don't think it'll be as big as like
forsaken or anything but i hope i'm
wrong but just based on what they've
shown so far i'm pretty sure it's just
one destination um i'm pretty sure that
it's going to be pretty like
straightforward in terms of like our
goal like our goal is to kill sabathune
and you know take down all of her light
users um
and yeah that's kind of what i'm
expecting so far but
you know how you guys i don't know if
you guys feel like this but i feel like
once i've seen some of a destiny trailer
i know kind of what it's gonna be like
to play it and i remember when i saw
beyond light i was like all right i know
exactly what beyond light's gonna be
like it's gonna be like eight missions
we're gonna kill aramis at the end it's
gonna be like a forsaken where we kill
her underlings and then we hunt her and
and then their big cell is gonna be that
there's the new subclass like that'll be
it and it was pretty much exactly that
and like shadow keep when i saw that i
was like oh this is gonna be a super
short campaign i can just tell just
looking at it and then that was super
short so i don't know if you guys know
that but i kind of feel like i know
how long this thing's gonna be and how
it's gonna play out just based on what
we've seen so far just because i've
played so many destiny campaigns at this
point like we all kind of have a feel
for them you know i mean i was i will
chime in real fast
i would say i agree with everything
previously because we joked about uh
beyond light it was like we're gonna
kill her in the campaign and stuff like
that to me this one feels a little
different though
for some reason
from what i read when there's the
where's the reveal summary basically the
way they cover like the showcase recap
and they talk about
there's one so the witch queen is the
definitive destiny 2 campaign that
captures the special feelings for
memorable activities like presage and
our favorite dungeons that translates
them into a campaign experience for the
first time ever you have the option to
turn up the difficulty and sort it out
through legendary mode
so it's like i guess maybe i might be
personally also reading more into
legendary mode being their way to give
it more life as well but when they
mention things like pressage there's
also like
there's a unique feeling to presage on
itself as a mission and i think if they
can embrace like like regicide for oryx
was a very cool mission the feel the
music everything that went into
registered was special i'm hoping they
at least hit that level and me maybe a
little bit more maybe it's not the
destinations maybe it's the feel maybe
it's the quality maybe it's the voice
lines the dialogue the acting that goes
all into it that way maybe that's how
they crank it up maybe it's not like 20
missions long but what's in like the
eight or nine or ten missions that you
do play is
kind of on an epic level in scale
maybe
yeah i
mean go ahead travis if you have a quick
thought i was gonna say i just uh for
the legendary thing i hope that they
don't just crank up the difficulty
through legendary as as as a
modifier for the fact that the that the
campaign isn't super long because that's
that was my like inclination is oh
they're just adding a legendary mode
because then you have to play through
all eight missions twice and one time
takes you like three times as long that
was my if they do that then i'll be sad
so
during the reveal they specifically
say that if you like campaigns like doom
or titanfall or halo this will be the
this will be your campaign which
besides
destiny 2 vanilla
none of the campaigns for destiny have
ever been um sort of
uh
not cinematic but you can kind of do
everything at your own pace sort of
thing like i mean for a second it's a
great example of this work you do the
opening mission which is obviously where
they spend most of their money because
that machine yeah cutscene and all that
oh yeah that's a side tangent so usually
for a lot of like campaigns uh most of
your budget goes to the first and last
mission because the first mission you
want to hook players in and you want to
make this like awesome thing same thing
with shadow keep right the first mission
of shadow keep is completely different
from the rest of the campaign uh and i
would argue beyond light is also like
that too and then you also want to make
your last machine tv shows are also the
same thing
yeah finale right right that's where
they spend the most money to kind of uh
to get people hooked and then also to
satisfy your the people that made it
through because uh realistically from
like an engagement standpoint um i don't
have exact numbers but i've heard
developers say this a couple times with
various games that a lot of people
actually don't make it through
campaigns for a lot of games and so uh
from a like cross business side you know
you want to invest your money where
people are going to be engaged the most
yes is a little unique in this aspect
because there's so many different things
you can do
um
so
there's that there's that aspect and
then
sorry i forgot what i said at the
beginning before i went on this tangent
uh the
comparison oh yeah so they were there
yeah they compared to these campaigns
right and that's something they
generally don't do uh i thought it was
actually halo is one thing because they
worked on halo but compared to doom and
titanfall which are two other properties
that
they're shooters but they don't exactly
uh fit in that destiny
genre and so i think this campaign will
be
it's gonna be like the vanilla destiny 2
experience where you're sort of locked
into doing this campaign and then once
you're done
you can actually exit and kind of do the
other things that destiny offers um
taking king i think is the gold standard
for how a destiny campaign story should
be done because it does this really
talked about this in one of his really
old videos but it does this really smart
tiered system where a player can drop
off at any point but you're
each section is kind of geared towards a
different player you have the main story
that you kind of sit through and play
through then you have the post story
stuff which is the ticket taken
of the raid and each each point was
really great for every type of player
because if you're just a casual player
you play the campaign you're done if you
kind of wanted to dive in a little bit
more you had to take in war and you
could do that and then if you were the
hardcore player you're building up
towards the raid and i think forsaken
like almost got this right but ever
since then they've never really nailed
this there's like a huge disconnect
between
the campaign and what you're doing at
the end game and i think they know that
because if they've talked about this
uh before so i think this campaign
specifically will be very different uh
maybe not in terms of mission structure
but um in terms of like how we're
engaged with it versus the other stuff
because otherwise they wouldn't compare
it to a strictly single
doom and titanfall halo halo is
different but like
those two games where does the forsaken
get it wrong though because forsaken had
that sort of like campaign you had to
finish and then it had it was the grand
city is like the end game location and
then a raid after that
the the grind was absurd you had to
grind to get the talisman or whatever i
don't think that's going anywhere with
this guy with this one guys well they've
they've uh
the last two raids um deep stone crypt
and vlog they've been very okay with
like all right you don't have to play
that much um you know with contest mode
everything the grind is not really oh
you're talking to the grind to the raid
i was just thinking the grind in general
like end game the weapon crafting is
going to be the longest yeah yeah like
yeah the the the thing that taken king
i think did really smart was to take in
war which was this like post game
here's what happens now that you've
killed oryx the first time
um and and it was also unique because
you got to go to all the destinations
and kind of view them in a different
lens with all the taking stuff and the
quest was actually rewarding it was i
remember at the time we didn't have a
lot of narrative stuff in destiny so
that was like another avenue
and they've they've sort of followed
that model with the yearly expansions
but they've they've never had that taken
war bridge
that allowed you to understand why you
were going into the raid and and that
narrative beat um and so i i think with
this they will achieve that um because
this her something's their own world
seems like it's going to be a
dreadnought level if not bigger yeah um
style area where there's a lot to
uncover a lot to do a lot of quests uh
they haven't shown any vendors usually
they show a vendor
in their reveals and they show any
vendors so i mean
i wouldn't be surprised if there's a
high vendor that we interact with
somewhere and that's kind of the
campaign quest
area
i also think there is another
destination um that they're they're not
showing yeah
i don't think it's an endgame
destination and i'm not saying that
because the leak reference is another
destination i actually legitimately
think there is like another destination
that um that they will use what do you
think it is
i don't know so somewhere i i i think
they wouldn't do a single destination
um
or if they haven't passed two though
well i mean we got
cosmodrome
we did what was i'm sorry we got beyond
light so we got european cosmodrome at
the same time and god's been joined at
the same time cosmodrome is free to play
yeah so yeah well they're all free to
play technically it's also definitely
not an end game you don't even have no
yeah you look at the gold here yeah it's
just an additional space that's all uh
yeah europa and the moon are also not
end game destinations whereas
like the dreadnought and um the dreaming
city
they specifically call those end game
destinations and they're calling the
throne world an endgame destination so
that's why i think there there will be
like a sort of a tangled shore
style area where it's this like
intermediate area that you're
interacting with it's like it may just
be like the swamp area versus getting
into her lake throne as well so it could
be yeah something uh
cog do you got anything about the
campaign or you
said yeah just you talk about the just
in general with the difference the
difficulty part you know how big you
might think it might be is it going to
be is it going to live up to like that
description that i read do you think
it's yeah they they got their chest out
they talking way too strong they like
got a war you you what you throwing yes
i was shocked i was like how dare you
destiny you throwing yourself
it got a war in it like they jumped out
of here
yes oh
bro i was like okay that was one of the
games they said if you like campaigns
like that if you like yeah if you like
campaigns like god oh my god the game of
my generation for ps4 so i'm like
to me
they got their chest out they clearly
are excited again this is me seeing
bungie typed with explanation points on
twitter so at the end of the day you for
you to be talking this strong you got
something you feel extremely confident
about and um yeah the difficulty thing
was a great thing like that that was one
of my always been one of my issues one
that you couldn't replay the campaign
which always drive me nuts because i
felt a lot of red war was great you know
when the cinematics and learning what
was going on sometimes you want to
replay that and then the second thing
was the difficulty was way too easy and
e you know how we feel about
doing
missions and killings all
in seconds and yes you know what i'm
saying is like oh he's the worm god of
this and just smashed him out and just
killed him
yeah like like it never felt good to be
able to super punched him yeah like i
did all this and i'm just like nah fam
that that ain't it so
to me i love what i'm hearing i think it
will meet expectation um i don't know
how long it is i can't that part i'm not
sure but
i feel from a quality standpoint they
are pulling out all the stops for this
campaign there's no that you don't you
don't even mention yourself with these
campaigns unless you feeling real real
good so that's what i got what about you
dave
sorry to cut in they've uh they're
definitely up to the like storytelling
they also mentioned this in the
um
in the presentation they said long long
are the days of of reading lore cards in
the game and you know they evolve the
narrative is now delivered to you in
some way
yeah even if it's just text on the
screen while someone's talking through a
radio transmission or something right
like that's that's leagues beyond
reading it on a page
or an armor right and so i think with
this campaign
they're going to pull out all the stops
and do cinematics and you're gonna be
way more involved because you wouldn't
you wouldn't i don't know you just
wouldn't compare yourself to doom or
titanfall which are linear single-player
campaigns if you weren't doing exactly
or halo halo
if you weren't doing exactly that
yeah i agree dressage does that too and
they say that
i agree yeah i hope you guys are right
i was like yeah i was like i would i
would like to be pleasantly surprised
because yes i do not want to kill
another i do not want to kill anybody in
a campaign who's at a god level sorry
just not yes you mean you don't like
killing zoll in a strike
you didn't like that no i'm sorry that
didn't work that didn't feel justified
for a hive warm god that's like the size
of the empire state building swirling
around and i'm just shooting him in the
crit spot so
tangent here what's always bothering me
about that strike is is this gigantic
worm that's like roaming around
rasputin's you know servers and bunkers
and he conveniently misses the gigantic
room that rasputin is in where he is
yeah
his house that also happens to be like
right behind that area that you're
fighting zolan um yeah so yeah just
starting to do that that's right
like just saying that's just just saying
i had this i had to suspend this belief
they also finally built a new mob type
and they've only used it there
like that's the thing every boss is just
like a bigger version of an existence oh
yeah a good point yeah good point yeah
even airmass is just like a you know a
cow it's like okay well we fought a
million of those but they created like a
giant worm and they only use it one time
there's no yeah
hey they do that more often man i just
yeah anyway that's a complaint i'm gonna
have
uh other things in the deluxe edition
we've got weapon crafting we've covered
new glave weapon archetype new raid
which we know is going to be on the
pyramid ship in the swamp exotic gear
the six player match made activity we
know those are going to be a thing
uh you've got pre-order incident unlocks
the throne world exotic ghosh shell the
enigma exotic emote legendary emblem
then we get to the deluxe edition
exotic smg catalyst and ornament
so that will be kind of your season pass
we're not even there yet dude i'm not no
calm down [ __ ] i'm not even touching
that one for a while
nope nope put it nope put it no it's put
it down
put it down put it down
nope
i got one of my theories shot by the way
access to season 16 17 18
and 19. we have four seasons
that was one of those things i was you
would they wouldn't get rid of that
revenue i know i know you said that but
we also said you know for their sake
like we didn't you know it would be nice
to see bigger fewer seasons but
they're sticking with their plan
to my giant grinning happiness
two dungeons released in year five
nothing about we'll get to that
but you've got raid
in season 16 i'm guessing dungeon season
17
18
d1 remake raid which everybody is
guessing we know what that one is and
then 19 another dungeon like that is
probably the fullest year for
in-game content in a long time
so when you got all that information we
have four seasons we have a raid coming
back we have two other dungeons
okay i got first which raid do you guys
want can i get a crucible map please
[Laughter]
the reason they told us that a couple
weeks ago is so that when we heard
nothing at the stream we wouldn't be too
disappointed they're trying to placate
you
because i i bet you they get the bad
news out of the way on a friday get the
bad news out what's the expression
rip the band-aid off
from the jump so you set expectation to
what the hell you ain't getting
they've been doing this for years now
we're like leading up to a hype cycle
they yep they deliver all the kind of
like not great stuff but and they try to
like wrap it up as like as this nice
thing yeah and then the hype cycle
starts and you most people have already
forget we forgot yeah i'm so mad about
this thing oh pretty stuff oh
oh we don't we don't because we're hard
we
we keep up with the cycles and we know
but like the average person
you know they've they've forgotten about
that but to your point trap you're all
correct
so which raid do you want and which one
do you expect cox come on we don't even
need to answer this we know what it is
come on what do you which one do you
want which one do you want which one we
want i could say we but i actually would
guess you all on a different one
no i want king's fall damn it
you always put like um wrath on the
machine i hate no no no no king's full i
say rather machine is probably one of
the more fun raids out of all raids like
but i don't rank it how kings fall is
come on
y'all understand my vog fanboy this does
not just you know disrespect the
greatness that is kingsville i still
recognize it as as the the raid of all
raids a man's rage right like
you're in there all day and you hard
mode oryx like i'm never going to
disrespect that rain it's just a fun
little thing we you have with
significance and importance and all of
that stuff but now it's got to be and it
better i'll tell you what it better not
be
if they bring that
dungeon of a raid back first
oh daddy don't do it daddy don't say it
daddy no no no here's my theory here's
my theory so
during an interview with kind of funny
two years ago luke smith confirmed
something that we've known for a long
time based on the jason schreyer
articles which was that the original
raid for destiny 1 was supposed to be a
combination of crota and kings yes
correct when you defeated crota you were
going to go into king's fall and that
was going to be the fault but it was too
long and a lot of other things went
wrong with destiny one in the beginning
and so they they split them up
i think
they are going to do that again
i think they're because i think quota as
much as people want crota and and want
it if they label it as a dungeon
yeah some people are saying bring it
back as a dungeons
say bring it back as an extending strike
and then some people like oh rework it
to make it you know a little longer and
more fleshed out i think inherently it's
just too short of a
thing and the age of triumph version of
that raid is i think is the definitive
virtual that is a fun version of the
raid it's not buggy it works fine but
it's still kind of short so i think
you kind of trim a little bit of the fat
off king's fall because king fall is a
pretty long raid
and then you do the original vision
where you combine it you beat you beat
crota and then like luke smith said you
jump into the the oversoul and then you
go into oryx's throne world
i like to bring back that's fire however
business however business
and business said we're gonna sell you
that old thing
now you had it be touched up and we
gonna separate this and space out our
legacy rotation
you know saying that we want to do a
good job i mean that's all but i love
your idea yeah isn't vogue a free to
play raid yes
yes it is so i i think they would also
make this raid free to play
i i think that so okay let me because
they're definitely not going to spend
that much time on yeah i think it's
called so
well they
kind of spent some time on on vog oh so
so here's something that they that i've
noticed since season of opulence they
learn the season of opulence that having
a strong pre-expansion season is
important because it gets your player
engagement up and also making um
activities that people actually want to
grind because that was the first time we
actually had both those things
uh and we saw their arrivals where they
made
the activity wasn't great but the grind
was there the engagement was there the
story was starting to deal and now this
season is definitely like all the
learnings this entire year have finally
come
forward and this year they added on
putting a raid in the middle of the year
so we didn't have a a
garden salvation situation where you
went an entire year yeah whatever way
because remember forsaken we got
scriptures in the past yeah we had two
raids for that entire year and then we
were still doing this raise even after
cardinal salvation came out right but
garden was only a relevant rate and so i
think they've learned now that you they
need to have two raids and so the
dungeon announcement also
uh kind of pads that out because every
every three months now
uh presumably you're getting uh a raid
lighting that is experiencing fire can
we can we we highlight that y'all like
that is huge like
i i never expected that and and to me
that i had got accustomed to saying you
know what
realistically the one
raid a year cadence is probably what
they can handle i did not think we were
getting this bro that was huge so the
double dungeon is impressive
i will say the using of older content to
do these remastered rates makes it much
easier because if we could say
because i mean you're going to have
kings fall theoretically yeah i guess
you have crota you could maybe do in
year 9 and you have maybe wrath that you
can do in year 10 but i'm like
technically they've got enough they
could barely space them out to use the
old ones and
at least have that remastered raid each
year
but i was like i think the bigger thing
for me is just the dungeons because
those are not small
they design them to be soloable then
they designed the like the balance
between multiple people
those are like worlds that they build
that have
almost just not as much to a raid but
almost for like the art the world like
some mechanics to them puzzles
like the dungeons i think are going to
be each of those dungeons is probably
more work than it takes to get kings
falling
kings follows a lot of art and systems
and functionality that goes with the
engine but like each dungeon is
they don't do it that often the fact
that we get two is
surprising something uh kind of critical
to note here is um
bolts of glass a lot of the assets uh
i'm assuming i'm not a developer a lot
of the assets were already kind of in
the d2 engine in various places
obviously there's some new stuff and new
looks and and the vex on you uh but with
kingsfall or even crota
um a lot of those assets are already in
the game in various places or have been
in the game in various places so i think
from a development standpoint again i'm
playing armchair developer here
i'm assuming it's
a little easier for them to
to get that oh yeah through the finish
line than than it is say like a wrath of
the machine where everything in that
raid doesn't exist in destiny 2. yeah
that's what you're saying
my theory
i i don't think there's a chance in hell
of there being a king's fall uh crota's
end combo i think that's just i don't
think it will happen yeah i just want it
yeah
i i think king's fall gets remastered
and i think that they add a story reason
for why we're replaying it mm-hmm either
savage is gonna be still alive sabathun
is still alive and she's doing
commentary like reliving the time we
killed her brother that she didn't get
along with or she's dead and for some
reason crota or sorry oryx is is is
narrating over the the uh wow
the raid i i think i think they they do
a little bit more than they did on vault
because the thing with vault is it's
sort of hard to add story elements to
that a because it's
kind of self-explanatory and b because
there's sort of a faceless or at least a
voiceless enemy whereas oryx and
sabathune and the whole
legacy of the hive and the story of the
hive is so rich
that i think there's an opportunity to
at least like have sabbath do like voice
drips in between each of the uh
encounters and give sort of like a story
reason a meditation for why we're going
back and fighting orcs in his throne
world so i think you know maybe maybe
it's accessible from savathun's throne
world and it's sort of like this memory
that she keeps of the time her brother
was was dead or maybe we hear like what
she learned from watching us do that to
her her brother i think they add some
sort of like story reason to it but they
they just remastered king's fault it's
the one that makes the most sense given
what we're doing uh in the next
experiment that was actually
surprised sorry that uh they didn't
include like pray death at all in in
vogue like i knew they weren't getting
yeah zero story to that rate it's just
like here's an activity go
right yeah and they were kind of upfront
about that where they said it's not
really gonna tie into stuff but it
happened to be a vex season two so i
thought okay maybe
a little bit because there were some
missions in taking king that sort of
gave us like uh a lot of answers to that
enclosure and they they kind of didn't
do that which uh i thought was
surprising but also in their defense fog
exists in like the legends director
and i think the description for that uh
somewhere either in game or outside game
uh refers to how this is like past
things that are happening like it's not
technically right like it's not in the
lore of what's going on now that's where
i was going to go with that
i could just see it just existing kind
of in a in a vacuum again where yes
exactly what i was going to say
yeah basically that no just like the way
they did vlog is what i expect for
taking king be like hey this is in the
raid
it's free
but there's no connection story because
we've gone through oryx's story in
taking king then we went to king's fall
threw him out into the universe and
kicked off other events but yeah there i
don't i think that will be the one they
remastered because it is obviously the
biggest one there's a tie to hive it
makes too much sense with the year but
sadly i don't see them putting a whole
lot of narrative connection to it at all
because
it's like three years ago i don't know
how they actually would tie it back in
unless you're just like
hey do you want sabbath to put you out
there could put you in a dream but
that's about it and dream is kind of
cheap so i was like i don't really see a
way to do that that's their whole dlc
idea it's a wonderland i i just think
there's too many opportunities with this
one to canonically tie it into like
sabbath i want to be fine like narrate
over it or something i and they did it
with deep stone crypt there's to
narration over that entire uh that raid
where clovis is talking to you right so
i think i mean
i think there's opportunity but i mean
that one titan with
yeah
so an interesting tidbit for destiny 1
uh with king's fall and wrath they
actually wanted to do audio while you
were playing but they couldn't because
of uh console limitations and so when d2
came out and callous talks to you and
leviathan that that's where they finally
got to realize it and then they've
realized that that's also
uh an important aspect of the raid
because you you get information and sort
of oh yeah the world building and it
obviously works now
but just a little little side thing so
it would be cool to actually get king's
fall
if works was talking to us because
believe it or not orcs does have a voice
actor he does speak english
uh well albeit only a few words but he
does talk so i might be
it would be cool to get that
if we assume we get that right yeah to
me i'll make sure um uh travis that you
said is fire that's a dream i hope it in
the most perfect way i hope they do that
i do think it's kind of what e is saying
and i think that you're probably right
yeah i think you know what i think this
is this is literally what me and e used
to complain about when we first started
which is like why they don't have a
legacy rotation every week of you know a
raid or whatever i think this back yeah
right
that's what this is so it's like because
the whole to me the whole theme of this
as we continue on was
every core thing that most hardcore
destiny players have complained about
has been addressed in some form and i
the the the rotation of a raid
in some form with this legacy stuff i
think is where they going and i i like
it but hey we'll see which one of those
i i'll take a voice actor i'll take some
some contacts i'm with all that if if
the bunch is there yeah i just i'm
excited i get two dungeons i'm pumped
actually we get three
and the 30th anniversary pack coming out
in december actually which is
now you can do it
the return of the king the return of the
not the golden gun
but the gold-plated ornate
rocket launcher of wolf backgrounds the
aller horn gallohorn however you want to
say it is returning with a callous
catalyst as well
and and they did say it's guaranteed
from the dungeon correct
and
you gotta pay for it
that's why it's guaranteed so i didn't
want to ask you guys as we get into this
now
is the discussion of
pricing
so
which queen is
40 by itself correct
then the deluxe is 80 which has
70.
it's 80 on steam i thought right so no
because it's a hundred dollars for the
whole thing with uh i'm gonna go to
steam give me a second
which unless you get a discount on the
30th if you buy it for 100.
well so which queen is 39 the deluxe is
99 and then the deluxe they're the
deluxe plus 30th is 99 deluxe is 8.79 so
it's 80 bucks
wow oh so this is that give me you guys
chances
all together that's cool
okay so that's because you usually think
it's expensive yeah but also what did we
just say how much are we getting
for our value this time
you're getting two raids two dungeons
the campaign
now granted we've talked about the
crucible maps we only get like what one
two three four i think
i don't know what strikes
don't mention that
i'm saying the whole picture you get
seasons 16 17 18 and 19. you get four
seasons of content
and all of this stuff for 80 bucks
you think of how many hours you're gonna
put in over the course of a year into
eighty dollars
obviously it's worth it but with the
fact that so much of the game is
stripped out and replaced with micro
transactions
why do we still need to spend this much
money because think about the armor sets
the ghosts all the stuff that the emotes
all that stuff you can only get in
eververse
it just seems like their model has sort
of evolved to the point where it's weird
that we're paying for seasons we're
paying for expansions
and then seasons passes and then side
expansions to celebrate the 30th
anniversary and then we have
microtransactions all over the place
okay in the grand scheme for the 30th
revenue streams 30th anniversary if you
buy it separately is 25 some people are
gonna say that's a lot how much is one
set of armor in this game
one cosmetic set of armor
okay
ten bucks is that a fifteen isn't it i
thought it was
okay
you get a dungeon you get the exotic the
catalyst and an ornament which is a
cosmetic you pay for
new weapons you get the thorn armor set
you get the bungie streetwear outfit the
marathon marathon themed outfit a unique
ornament sparrows ghosts and other
things so the cos you could buy one set
of cosmetic armor for 15 bucks or you
get everything i listed for ten dollars
more and if you buy it as a bundle it's
five dollars more than one armor set
but you're making my point for me
if one set of armor costs ten dollars
and we know they're making money hand
over fist with the micro transactions
why are we still paying for expansions
typically in a game where you pay full
price tag to get an expansion i would
expect no micro transactions to be on
the other side because that's how
they're getting their money and now
we've got to both of those models and
then we've got season passes on top of
it so much a lot i was like
my only guess is because
they don't want to go to a subscription
and this is their balance between them
because if you do a subscription this is
how you support the live services you
have season 16 17 18 raids dungeons all
the work that goes on is a steady inflow
of cash
that i don't buy that the the
subscription model is basically dead
because games like fortnite and apex are
literally free and they just make money
off microtransactions in season passes
and they're hugely successful yeah their
player base is also substantially larger
than destinies
so any like you have like an nfl release
and like you have you know a five
percent of that population buys a skin
that population is a hell of a lot
bigger than ours who might buy a piece
of armor every so often
i know bungie's doing fine because
they're building a studio but also on
the other side they are releasing
they're not just doing like here's some
skins here's a dungeon here's armor
here's the other pieces there's more
that goes into each of these i mean the
fact like tassie has said it before and
i think he said it's like
ten dollars for a season that we get the
voice acting the armor the weapons the
destinations and everything that we get
in the ten dollar season is undervalued
honestly like ten dollars for a season i
agree i agree with exotics
because you know they're making money
from microtransactions like they're they
definitely don't buy all of those and
there's they're making they've got to be
making money off that so my question
either they value their their dlc
at the cost that they need it to be to
make their money back or they do micro
transactions and sort of supplement that
yeah what do you got so so i the last
point you made that's where i was going
to get that was my conclusion to what i
was going to say so they're triple
dipping
they know
they know that casual joe schmoe who
only buys the yearly expansion
is gonna pay the 40 bucks and he doesn't
care about the dlc maybe he'll spend
money or she will spend money on you
know an ornament or something whatever
and now they've double dipped on that
person but let's say joe schmo
accidentally bought the deluxe edition
so now he's got all the seasons so now
they triple tipped on this guy oh but
now he wants the cosmetic uh he wants to
transmog his thing this armor piece
because he played in year one but he
didn't play in year two and three okay
he doesn't really want to do the grinds
he's gonna pay for that too
it
i agree with you it's completely icky
and like for us as like normal like
people that play a lot it's kind of
scummy and let's not forget let's not
forget character boosts
that too character that's been going
right are they still doing that how much
of this stuff you guys are talking about
is optional you get one for free
cosmetics
of course it's optional but the whole
point of the free to play model is that
the optional stuff covers the cost to
make it free for the people who don't
pay for it but and that's why it's so
expensive that's why it's fifteen
dollars for an armor set but like right
it's just yeah like teddy's saying it's
a lot of goodness so i think that i'm
with you
they have intentionally undervalued the
seasonal stuff because they know
they want people to buy that because
they're going to make the money back on
the microtransactions because they
they've done the calculus for the supply
and demand of their virtual cosmetic
item and say yeah it's 15 bucks a seat
for an armor set but they know people
are gonna buy the most amount of that
armor set at that price and they they
make all the money back tenfold probably
over the course of just one season let
alone the entire year like i'm assuming
i don't people also buy season past
levels
they do at the end of the season that's
another thing
um so so much i do it's just so much man
we view it as kind of this is like
really scummy but like i mean we also
play the game an absurd amount and so
i see i saw i know where this is going
this question is the dungeon the
anniversary pack worth the money because
it is a little steep
um
but
the the concept of value economically is
kind of hard to
uh define because it's each indiv it's
up to each individual to define what
values 45 dollars for me is kind of
whatever right like i else but i play
this game of crap yeah i have like 4 000
hours in this game of course i'll spend
25
on a dungeon and gallahorn of durr like
that's that's not even a question
um
but i i could see this being an issue
for you know let's say you didn't play
destination you played beyond light you
were kind of like ah beyond lights all
right this guy travis reviewed it it was
kind of okay whatever like and then you
see this anniversary thing like well i'm
a halo fan but 25 bucks
okay i'll i'll buy it and then you buy
witch queen and then you buy the next
like
it
it's the cycle right and they touted on
their live stream oh we have these 20
million
uh active players or whatever whatever
the the verbiage they were using
you wouldn't say that uh if you weren't
like just reigning money in every day
like
you wouldn't you wouldn't put that out
there i also agree the subscription
model is completely dead like i think
that just doesn't that just doesn't work
and so this is their this is their weird
solution to an evolving um
evolving market i think they're just
ahead of everyone else as much as we
don't like the systems i think they're
they're doing it way smarter than
everyone else and i think it's unfair
comparison to compare them to fortnite
and april i agree that's why i kind of
watched travis yeah you can't compare to
the fortnight
a competitive experience whereas destiny
is primarily a a
pve experience where those games are
more accurate right and and in their
core
the gta online
gta online
but the differences
it's an online pve game they add content
and it's always free
and they make all the microchips they
make so much money off shark codes
exactly you don't think bungie's doing
the same thing why did they have to
charge you for the content then i just i
just wish that it sounds like
we're talking about the evolving model
and i agree the industry is evolving in
huge ways but it seems like every time
bungie evolves to
tweak their their model they don't get
rid of the old one they just add a new
one onto it like oh we're gonna charge
you for this new thing okay so does that
mean we're not paying for the oh no no
you still pay for those but now we're
evolving to find new ways to charge you
and i'm like well what the that's not
like giving me a break somewhere like
there's got to be something's got to
give in this model because i've been
complaining about this for years it's
super unpopular every time i bring it up
there everybody's like support bungie
who are you
and you know and i'm just like
i agree with you i'm just the guy i'm
like you i don't care about the money
either like 25 bucks is nothing because
i play this game all the time i'm more
just wondering like on a on a
model level like does this model make
sense
in any way and every time i think about
it i'm like jesus these guys are making
they got to be making billions of
dollars off of this and and no one
questions them nobody goes like all
right well we're still paying five five
different ways six different ways that's
why i think they're ahead of everyone
else yes
i think they have against the consumer
right i mean they're ahead of everyone
else
in a way that is not helpful to the
consumer
but that's just business like anything
like don't we want them to exist so we
don't want them to exist at some point
okay but but don't don't we want
consumers to
have
advocates of course that's not good for
them making money obviously it's working
for them but shouldn't shouldn't someone
who's on a show about destiny maybe go
hey but as a consumer this sort of feels
a little off balance and maybe
absolutely
absolutely yeah that's all i'm saying is
i want that to be voiceless
but it's also like you i have questions
i mean as old as we are we also know how
much games used to be
when you had a nintendo 64 game that was
eighty dollars
stuff has gotten cheaper somehow at
sixty dollars you have a 10 season for
destiny that almost has more content
than an n64 game at 80
and that crap was 30 years ago so it's
like you have the amount of work that
goes into voice acting weapon design
exotic quests
exotic weapons all of this stuff
like goes in and that's a ten dollar
season right and you're telling me they
if they have a chance like the stuff you
like list is optional transmog optional
do you want to look pretty cool do
people want to do it yeah they're
literally tugging at the want to be
pretty
they're they're gonna get after the
desires
but i'm also saying it's not required
right i will grant you it's optional but
are you saying that that stuff wouldn't
be in the game if it wasn't not in
microtransactions there wouldn't be
ghosts there wouldn't be speeders there
wouldn't be ships no no and that's that
would be i was gonna say i was getting
it to the other to sell it to you
separately getting to the other side of
that that's the balance where i will say
they do need because for me i'm still
beyond like annoyed pit of heresy
doesn't have like an armor set and this
actually has a thorn armor set so it's
that balance of where they said they
were gonna be putting more stuff in the
game and they haven't that's the most i
agree with it and it's like and it leans
so far into eververse if they walk along
between both of these if like if i can
earn a thrown world set over here and
then you give me the bungee street where
in the ever store
i am totally fine with that if there is
the only cosmetics you're ever going to
get over there
some of it does need to be earnable if
they if they balance that better then
yeah they can throw everything in the
ever store that they want you can charge
for other levels and other things of
that nature fine but it's just like some
of the stuff needs to be earnable and as
long as they make that a decent balance
for me i'm okay but it's like buying
stuff for transmog buying other levels
all those other things those are
optional if somebody has the disposable
income to
skip steps and that's usually an option
but if you want to put the time into
grind
there should be something there but also
again it's an eververse store you have
artists just sitting over there like hey
we got some downtime let me make an
awesome set of armor cool throw it in
there you want to spend some money on it
cool but you don't have to
but the balance for me is like pitiful
the pit of hair say armor like not
having armor and then like the ship and
the sparrow or in everest later those
are the pieces that did frustrate the
crap out of me because those should have
been in game if those types of things
like the ghosts the ships the sparrows
are in some activities but then there's
like a beach ball in eververse
that's the balance that i would like
cog yeah i i totally agree with you
obviously i want the studio to be
successful yes i'm just saying like
i i wanna i'm trying to speak up to my
poor uh game pass free to play
blue ghost you know a green speeder and
all that you know stuff he's got to live
with respect no i feel you travis you
know i i know exactly where you're
coming from i think there's validity
there i think
you know
one two two things one
the business aspect the optional aspect
two another part that i feel that we
forget a lot is
how
insatiable we are as a community with
the consumption of the content
and
where on one hand we say they're making
all this money
and then the other hand we
we blaze through the content and say
it's not enough they need to be giving
us this they need to be giving us that
and you know my my issue
what i do empathize is from a
development standpoint when you talk
about dungeons raids or whatever you
know these are time-consuming things and
when you look at the telemetry of it and
the analytics for example like a vog and
a king's fall
to me it always bothers me when they
look at the numbers and to see the
percentage of people who are not playing
that right so that's the other thing i
have to think about it from a balance
standpoint and the last point i kind of
with teddy i don't know i thought teddy
was gonna go here but
i want to mention is
we know
they they i which you trav what a triple
dip i know where you going i know where
you going you you are not wrong right
you're not wrong it's like a six times
right you are not discovered
from advocacy i gotta commend you love
you are that wrong
what i will say is this showed me
that with this long season coming in we
were like damn that's a long season
before witch queen right what this show
me is quarterly
yeah they are not missing out on revenue
like like that spot where which queen
was supposed to be
they are they are going to infuse
something
that you are going to now pay that old
bottle price right and they did it for i
can't from businessmen a ballroom cog
right now this was perfect you put the
beloved most coveted exotic weapon in
the history of the game you know damn
well that was their that was their ace
in the hole that they were waiting to
use this was this was masterful business
we used to joke with my clan mates that
uh if any if destiny ever like went
really really downhill there was a oh
[ __ ] hit the gallows
pete parsons jason jones had like two
nuclear keys and they had to like insert
them this was like a huge running joke
and they had to like you know oh pull
pop the lids up and look at each other
and go all right three two one hit the
thing
and that that didn't happen
they probably realized that that they're
like oh destiny's in good place you know
we got this road map for the next couple
years we could just give them gal horn
it doesn't matter and they kind of
looked at each other like all right hit
the button man like whatever it doesn't
matter anymore
all right here's the witch queen final
shape y'all you see here's the budget
here's this how much all this good cars
how we gonna cover the hit the gala
button bro hit the button they go they
coming in droves we'll give them some
skids but we will rework a couple of old
uh uh raids you know what i'm saying do
some old ass assay gonna be too much
work on that right and then we'll get e
we'll hit him with some new dungeons you
know what i'm saying and then that's how
we get we get this revenue stream back
on point we got that studio what is it
amsterdam we got matter that we gotta
make that game right so trav you know i
feel you bro you know what i'm saying i
just think the ballroom went out
the door said
yeah
i will say this uh 100 agree with you
i'm just saying the boardroom's always
going to win i think somebody needs to
be there to at least be like consumers
like so
you guys are getting a little squeezed
right now on somebody
so they have mentioned occasionally on
record that
uh they kind of didn't like the holiday
release for
their expansion and i think that was
that's just a relic of the activision
model yeah yes actually we're forced to
um and we kind of saw those would be
online where they pushed it and and it
still did really well but we've seen
this happen a couple times where destiny
sort of gets cannibalized by other games
because it always comes out really early
in the holiday cycle and so i think with
witch queen
i think ultimately the following
expansion after which queen their goal
is actually to push it further into the
spring because what we've seen in the
last five or six years is that games can
actually have a spring launch yes it
would be super successful uh because i
it wasn't you know maybe it was like a
decade ago i was gonna say it wasn't too
long ago but i forgot i'm old uh games
weren't coming out fridays they were
coming on tuesdays and why was that
happening because video game developers
were afraid of movies they were like we
can't we can't release a video game on
the same day the movie's coming up
that's crazy and then what happened
nintendo was like oh we don't care we're
just gonna do it on friday and then
bethesda was like what if we do skyrim
on friday oh okay we can do this on
friday this is fine like there's no
problem with this and so we we've seen
this now they're bigger than movies
right now bigger than movies and then
after that we saw with the launch of
last generation that games can come on
in the spring and totally be successful
it doesn't yes that does not affect i
mean nintendo put a console out in the
spring that's unheard of and it's the
best-selling console so i think they're
i think they're releasing which queen on
on the date they are because the date is
kind of unique and that's probably going
to play into it because bungie loves
numbers but i think
uh lightfall will release like late
spring or or mid spring and that's
that's their goal and so
uh
this this anniversary pack just
conveniently happened to line up with
their shifting and they were like oh
extra money dungeon
the fans are gonna love this we've had a
great year
but we'll just we'll you know triple dip
on that on that dopamine
yeah and make him pay for it
i agree i agree i mean i think this is
also sorry honestly i forgot yeah i
think this is also the answer to what
we've been asking for since destiny 2
came out which is put destiny 1 on pc
because they've been pretty um
adamant about about when when they bring
old content back they want to make it
meaningful and uh purposeful and by
giving us uh something on the cosmodrome
as well as gallihorn back uh it's sort
of evolving what we had in destiny 1.
and this goes for anything they brought
back not just not just loot cave 3.0
yeah literally
so
that's fair enough for the valley points
i don't think they'll ever do ever do uh
d1 on pc
frankly i don't think that the pc
players deserve it we had to suffer
through the d1 stuff they don't just get
the final version straight out of the
gate
i love it he's hilarious so i think that
is most of what i've got did anybody nab
a collector's edition by the way oh it's
already done i did i waited uh one hour
in that queue
oh yeah oh yeah
i got to the front of the line and i was
like
nah
i just did the electrical action figures
man
yeah i have the original i did i did the
100 digital version oh no actually you
did the same thing oh my phone okay yeah
well i did the
collector's edition of stuff without the
game and then i'll just go on steam and
buy the pc copy but yeah i did the i'm
getting the hive ghost
yeah absolute salute that's just like
i'm just gonna
there you go too strong just
all right well
here's a question
we're at two hours and 40 minutes yeah
we didn't even get to this joint we
gotta we gotta make a business decision
on something we have yeah this will be a
four-hour podcast
here's the question
yes we don't know how much other stuff
that we're gonna get into
okay in between now and next week
this is obviously big into witch queen
two hours and 40 minutes later we still
have seasons of loss but we're only a
weekend
we have the trials information which
trials still won't launch until
september 10th 10th so we've got another
week on that one and also we have the
twab with void 3.0 and all of that other
stuff right right
i don't want to steal up
i was going to say i don't want to steal
the discussion on some of this stuff but
is there anything you guys
want to save for next week or versus
talking about now because as you said it
would be a four hour podcast and it's
long this is witch queen hype that's why
we're here but also i know there's other
topics is there any specific one teddy
is our guest that you want to discuss
more than anything else are you like hot
on trials hot on the season of the lost
hot up void 3.0 is there anything
that you want to touch on maybe so we
can keep this within three
uh let's see what trials because i know
travis is probably itching to
go there i i would personally prefer to
talk about the i was just going to say
but but i think i was going to say
trials and season the loss of the least
time sensitive but if you're if you want
to talk about trials man i'll talk about
trials with you i'll talk about trials
because i i have some opinions on this
even though i'm not really a pvp player
i got one i i trials if you know i'm all
come on you ain't gonna pull my own talk
about trump um i did want to talk about
the void
the 3.0 i did want okay that's probably
the most time sensitive
yeah
yeah we're going to be here for a long
time
how about this anybody else sweaty how
about this
can we possibly do this in two episodes
we can keep recording now
we can do part one and part two is
videos and almost like if you guys want
to take a little intermission right here
then we can get into the other stuff if
you guys have to sleep i i technically
can't because i got something wait no if
you have today what do you got you got
to be done like seven minutes i was
supposed to be done for a while but i
ain't stopping this fire
obviously weird way to wrap up a podcast
but also like if you've got time
constraints and stuff that's what i'm
trying to respect because we're all like
i mean we've been on this thing for
three basically three hours that's why i
was like
is there
is there a time potentially you guys
would want to just like do kind of an
off air one like random saturday morning
or who knows just like just a chat about
stuff
later
what about this um
even though i know three pvp mains here
right and trials
don't you think we could kind of breathe
still do the trial stuff for the most
part i mean it's up to you it's up to
you what's up with you
you guys want to just hit trials real
quick breathe through trials do void
subclasses next week and then
everything
else well i know teddy you wanted to say
your stuff on trials how about you say
your stuff on trials yeah yeah and then
we can let that marinate for a week and
then extract more later on
the only thing i really want to say
overall i think the changes are really
positive and i think they're they're
finally in a lot of aspects of destiny
not just the new trials work they're
finally approaching just saying the
mentality that i've always in my head
i've wanted them to approach it at which
is
let people play the game they want to
play it and also let them
um
make it rewarding right like when trials
launched it wasn't it really did not
reward your time adequately and
destiny's done a really good job in the
last year of for the most part not in
every aspect it's rewarded your time
properly for the things you're doing
unless you're me and you just you want
like the absolute perfect thing then in
that case it's not worth the time but
like for most people
it it's getting there it's finally
getting to that point where things are
approachable and trials has
one of the big problems that trousers
had is the population problem crossplace
sort of solves this but the inclusion of
the freelance playlist and also being
able to solo queue i think also does
will there be issues absolutely hundred
percent like that is a i think it'll be
even worse than raid lfg stuff or or any
any raid solo matchmaking that could
ever possibly exist because it's a
competitive game mode versus a pve game
mode
um
my only real thing i really want to
touch on is the skill based matchmaking
bungie has never gotten that right even
in halo they never ever got it right
and
we're already actually seeing some some
pvp players are reporting uh negative
effects of some they believe there's
some background spm that was adjusted
this season and it's going back to the
old way where they're only playing the
top tier sweaty uh players right and
trials they've shown in the past so
unfortunately i don't have faith in them
to get this right i'd love to be proven
wrong though
they've shown in the past that if they
do um spm only or they weigh it towards
spm the connection sucks and it's not a
good experience and if you have a solo
like imagine you're duo q like travis
and i are playing and we're getting a
solo kid player
and the connection is terrible in this
lobby that solo cute players experience
they're never going to touch trials ever
again
or are likely never going to touch it
again um that travis and i would ever
probably do a q in trials but you get my
point right like right that could happen
that's that's something that likely will
happen because it happens in comp like
if if you solo q com
outside the freelance playlist
you can possibly uh get that duo queue
and i think that's an area that they
i think spm just
needs a complete rework and they need to
be really transparent about it um this
last year where they essentially removed
it from everything other than comp i
think has been made pvp a much more
enjoyable experience
uh and so to see it kind of come back in
what i assume is its original form
because they haven't specified it's just
it's very uh
i'm not okay with that but everything
else
i'm pretty happy with like it's
the new leveling system the new reward
system it's it's a smart um
it's it's a way better way of doing it i
will say too adding additional perks to
the weapons is kind of uh iffy as well
because the weapons already had kind of
a lot of trash perks
but
you know
beggars can't be choosers at this point
just something new i guess
no doubt drive
was like with relation to like just the
matchmaking i want to go deep trials
conversation because i know i can open
up i want travis i can open up for about
30 minutes because i listen to your part
of fireteam chat and you're going to go
a lot deeper so for now
yeah i'm not gonna i'm not even gonna
touch it i was gonna say like i think
you guys know if you if you wanna know
like my early thoughts watch fire team
chat we did an episode this week but i'm
not even gonna get into it because i
have a ton of thoughts here and i don't
really think i can condense them into a
small one and i've talked enough this
episode
we'll get we'll get it next week because
i want to go deeper on trials over the
like all the stuff that they're doing
because it is major but like with
regards to matchmaking cog travis do you
guys have any thoughts about skill-based
matchmaking ever being around yay nay
hate it love it just kind of you know
that was teddy's main piece
it could it could be good i don't think
it's been good in destiny i don't think
it will be in matchmaking and trials i
see as being a a pretty big disaster in
a lot of ways but that's just
yeah i i think a lot more
than the positive
exactly i i just i think they could have
fixed most of the problems with trials
without adding matchmaking and i think
matchmaking is really going to sting a
lot of people um so that's my feeling
out we'll go we'll go more into it on a
deep dive yeah next question most likely
yeah pretty much i actually agree
actually disagree
um i feel that
at the end of the day the overall
population in the game is more important
and i think at the end of the day
regardless if it's not going to be
perfect it's going to be flawed you need
people playing this mode and that's been
the problem and they can't get people to
play the bone i think part of it is you
know one the flawless a boss mentality
to
you know the solo queue for a guy like e
and get trying to get people together
the casual person
is just too intimidated to to for the
most part to do it and then when they
get you know pump stomp they're out so
and i think you just need to pull better
so look i know we could go up we we we
we could go i know you can you can you
can add you can add uh
you can remove the the flawless or bust
without adding matchmaking i should
specify like that it's not mutually
exclusive you can make it more rewarding
we'll get it we'll get into it
literally literally i know i can't
comment
i was going to say something else that
was completely different that i wanted i
wanted to mention but i forgot so it is
what it is we'll get it out but uh
interesting choice to see oh i remember
curious to see
with this change i know teddy well don't
you call trav don't like um
will this open up
nightfalls in the same manner
because now
it's far right those needed too yeah
those right because if they're going
there
is that the precursor to that i'm just
curious that was it and we'll revisit
this update yeah another time
yeah i mean
it's an interesting discussion the whole
skill bix matchmaking thing
i've seen it from both perspectives of
every match of sweaty versus having
somebody get stepped on some casual
games versus the other piece it a lot of
the skill based matchmaking
depending on how it's handled of course
and connect like is connection important
is it not
also usually comes from the perspective
of the person who's talking about it
because somebody doesn't want to be like
oh it's connection based every time cool
well i suck and i get stepped on every
time this kind of sucks on the other
side is every match sweaty
it's there's always so many debates on
that one how it's handled is one thing i
still wish they would do like some type
of ladder ranking system but that's a
whole different thing for another day
just actually show for one progress that
you could work on and to kind of type
all that stuff showing but overall
i don't know too much when it comes to
the skill-based matchmaking i played a
little
my games were i was stepped on most of
my games i think i had two wins and like
five losses that were rough so the
couple games that i did play i'm not
sure where i stand in all of that maybe
i'm just rusty which is also possible
but i think what i generally saw for
trials looks interesting but also like
outsanity and chat he said i'm not gonna
lie with these changes i may dabble in
trials and i think as cog said
for the population
to give it a shot
you have people that would never try it
in the first place
and i think some of the changes for me
the one that i hope actually stays the
most is freelance and we'll talk about
that more later that's the one i think
that actually can
as a separate node like if it's team
only and freelance only i think that
could be at least something that's worth
trying and we'll have this debate let
next week so that'll be a fun one
last point remember they added um
and what for the record i'm with y'all
on connection base
i'm with y'all actually don't think i'm
not um for the record the added the the
paid you got to have the expansion that
yes
that's we wanted that y'all know
for the for the free accounts to keep
not making yeah anti-cheat paywall which
we asked for before trials relaunched
then account recoveries also they went
after like the security features were
big that worth a mention for sure
my point is the four or five changes
they made that weren't matchmaking
probably would have solved most of the
problems okay
adding matchmaking adds a ton of
potential problems and to teddy's point
i think there's going to be a ton of
problems which i will
yeah we were visiting monologue yeah
if you guys enjoyed the show where have
you watched it you know on you know your
audio platform iron lords podcast
youtube channel ivanta's youtube channel
or just popped into the live stream
wherever you found this tune in next
week because you know
it's going to be a spicy meatball
but for now we probably should be
wrapping this thing up um
been a whole lot of witch queen talk we
still have as you said void 3.0 we
haven't discussed season the loss we'll
get a little more kind of meat to talk
about next week which will be good
um
the time gate is obviously a thing that
makes next week a little bit more to
talk about there as well because i'm
gonna have my opinions and not just the
vexes time game
there's there's travis for you uh but
man teddy thank you so much for coming
today um yeah thanks for having me
absolute blast of course having you on
but seriously like
um thank you for coming spending the
time and of course your opinions you're
always kind of bringing a good level
head but also amazing knowledge about
this game with way too many hours and
the perfect triumph score is still well
maybe not right now but it will be
it's uh
it's my greatest and worst achievement
in life
you're gonna frame it when destiny
retires that triumph score for this game
you're going to print and frame it and
cry every time you walk by that picture
my my goal actually is that's cute you
think they'll retire it
destiny 3 the triumph score continues no
they're trying to
i probably will stop after lightning
depending on what they do um obviously i
need to see what happens i mean final
shape or final shape i'm sorry uh but my
goal i've said this before i think to
all of you my goal is to take all the
pins and the
title pins that they release with each
title and just frame them and kind of
just put it up on a wall somewhere
you know kind of do that thanos thing
where i can sit on the sunset and look
at it and go i've accomplished
i'm done you're sitting overlooking that
okay have you have you bought all the
pins i have bought every single pin it
was like that's yeah that's your
infinity stones you just need to like
yeah i also have they've really similar
pins at like various events like pax and
guardian con i also have those as well
um
and so those will go i don't know i'll
make a collage somewhere
i will make a gentleman's bet with you
oh
fifty dollar bet
that you are not stopping after the
final shape
because he said he was stopping after
lightfall i was like how do you not play
final fantasy he said that erroneously
after i think that you're a lifelong
slave an indentured servant and you
ain't you ain't never getting out of
this game you're gonna be here until the
grave my friend till dawn comes to your
family
that's the only point where i could
potentially
step away and be done with this this
curse that i'm burdened with every
season
to get every damn triumph in this stupid
game that i love but like it's just uh
there's a lot of close calls but i wish
i would travel you ain't leaving
you
yeah if you get a decade of your life
into something and there's more of it
you're gonna see what happens next
that's um you know what this is teddy
this is you you just got shot in the war
and you're talking about how you were
going to open up that uh that that uh
uh that shoe store oh yeah when you got
back home yeah yeah and i'm like you're
don't worry buddy you're gonna
you're gonna it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be okay
and i'm and i'm just lying to you as i
watch your guts pop out of your stomach
you ain't never opening that soup shop
you know like oh my god that's what's
happening right now it's got dark real
fast um anyway uh teddy where can people
find you on what do you do
better question where can they find all
the stuff that you do
you can follow me on twitter at
teasingteddy i think it's on the stream
somewhere
all over the screen
i'm usually just uh posting memes and
and trolling travis or someone i work
with that's that's really all i use it
for
um i don't i don't assume i am planning
on streaming probably in at the end of
this year maybe next year that's what i
have this i don't know if it's on stream
but this thing back here somewhere um
i'm actually gonna build legos that's my
that's my ultimate goal but that's
that's like
i gotta settle and
okay get all my stuff together but thank
you for having me this is always super
fun it's always good to catch up the
family we got the face yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah we we could do this all day
like all day
yeah literally these four people right
here on this podcast could talk for an
extremely long time about this game
and the fact that we're all friends to
help sorry
yes so cool so cool i love everyone
telling you i was like this could be
gold did i get some vintage teddy and
trav banter i was like there's gonna be
fire great topics but you always kill it
man i gotta give you credit love your
analytical nature and i don't mind doing
an intro for you forget trap
[Laughter]
travis just bought his
so if i call you like three in the
morning which is six for you
can you can you give me an intro like
i'm feeling really depressed i don't
know kind of kind of just introducing it
he's like hey i'm getting ready for like
my marathon run can you give me a can
you give me a hype speech right now i
need it i need it
all i need though now there's no excuse
cross play i i need my i need my batch
made trials carry
oh i don't know
you're
you don't want to play with the pc
people oh okay yeah have you got tried
it have you ever tried mixed matchmaking
yet i i just did cross play last night
it's not that bad
it's not that bad but i can i can see it
being
kind of bad in like a competitive
environment iron banner will be like a
good litmus a good litmus test yeah
that comes out before trials um you kind
of see how it's gonna work but yeah i
think it trials
pc players it's just it's way too
sweet
daniel said great intro guys
podcast
we joked at the start of this thing like
our five-hour show intermission in the
middle and travis did the voice and
we're literally at the point you could
do that tonight it could easily be a six
hour show right now we are yeah we are
i don't even talk about crossplay either
that was like in the grand scheme i
actually don't know if we have a guest
next week teddy if you're around i made
you yeah
i wanted to bring you back bro
160 like somebody said an anime style
like 164-2x2
version
3.763 or something yeah unless he
doesn't want to break his 21 episode of
tradition because that's been the match
it's still the same episode it's just
part of the same episode
yeah also we already messed that up yeah
i know
we broke it but it's still i basically
it's every 21 episode anything past 20
minutes that's how i can't believe it
yeah that's how i mentally put it so
once he it can't be before 21. yes we
have to get him after that
part two
this is also the first time you've had
me at the beginning of the season you
usually always have me at the end of the
day
so we're speculating and kind of like
you know wrapping up the
what are you keeping up with what do you
plan that you can talk about of course
hero is doing things he can't
yeah i can tell you what i'm what i'm
playing this week i think i'm reviewing
the new man eater dlc uh truth quest for
ign you can read that on ign.com i think
it'll be up on tuesday and then i'm also
reviewing something
[Music]
can i talk about this probably not
exclusively i can uh i heard things i'm
doing a preview of a mmo game the dayz
zombie game there's some stuff going on
with that game that i'm gonna have uh
live early september which i have to dig
into nice yeah
cog what about you what's 17 you got
your lineup of like 17 podcast schedule
for this week bro
i don't even know how i'm awake
hashtag
it
like yeah it's is right here keeping me
awake look bro it's it's been i knew
this week was gonna be crazy gamescom
what i you know what it was as geek
you're like oh my god it's geek overload
but as a content creator you go oh my
god it's witch queen and gabe's coming
on the same day it's james called live
the next day then it's like defining
duke four hour with chess gordon and
then secret said
it was like this week was nuts and but
this is kind of the the one i was most
looking forward to because this was the
homies i'm like it's the homies so i
could chill he got me we good you know
what say so this one was funner to do in
a way because it was less work and it's
just you know the passion for we got for
this crazy ass game you know so that's
what it was but um yeah i'm almost there
i got i got one more i got one more
thing to get through and then you know i
kind of got to take a little downtown
for me other than that but not even
tomorrow all of it just just sleep but
what's down time i know what's that i
gotta play destiny bro like i got to
play like i got to get in there and do
more have you not even logged on yet
really i logged on
i know he logged on because he
high-fived me in the european dead zone
he added me on crossplay and he's like
he's also cameoed in a video because i
was like
oh hey there's cognito he joined my game
anyway
oh you said it while you recorded i
literally was like i got to see the
video because i was doing the um
ascendant anchor locations on the patrol
for edz and i'm going around i'm like oh
cognito's in there well let me do this
and i'm going to go say hi it's like
literally in the middle of a segment i'm
pretty sure i'd have to go look like
you got to add me you got to add me on
there yeah you got to give me your
bungee name yeah i didn't have your body
name and both of you i got to get your
budget in but it would just kind of like
i'm i'm on we're friends on xbox so
you'll already have mine yeah but i
don't i'm not connected to cog at all
we're not friends on steam or anything
so we're friends on xbox though
xbox we're just not friends yeah so we
you and i already are already yeah we're
already lists yeah yeah yeah i'm not on
any of his lists
yeah yeah that'll just drop the discord
later on we'll get them all in there
yeah no but other than that like i said
it was just it was fun i had to do it we
had i had to do the osiris move i had to
break time and space to get to my
i had to go through all the cross play
then i that i saw you had now navigate
the literal worlds internet just to find
your way into my game and high five
did i have i had that what is it the
companion emote the dual emote ready and
we did the facebook and i was like ah
we're good boy i had to do a tradition
and it's it's so cool
to see your name with the steam icon on
the list like that is so cool and shout
out to the fanboys that on xbox that
whenever they see uh playstation
controllers they go extra hard it's fun
it's good to see but not this is dope i
dabbed on some stadia controllers
i was shocked i was it's a it's a little
stadia control i'm never going to see i
was just like oh my god wait they got
the s is their logo on the thing it's
not the s yeah i thought it's i think
it's a controller
controller playstation with the
controller yeah
i haven't seen the stadium yet there's
12 of them it's going to be kind of hard
i i could have sworn yeah there's 12 of
them if y'all see one maybe there are
some places all i know is that they were
they were having some trouble in pvp and
i was just like who are these guys
welcome to real reaction times for
everybody else sorry it's called
yeah stream delay
we didn't even talk about the uh the
controller changes we need to i know we
didn't get
same guest as long as we can sneak him
in here again
he's
uh i don't think i got anything going on
no doubt it works because we're gonna
have a little more to talk about uh for
me uh what you got yeah keeping up with
this stuff trying to orchestrate my
games
of what's coming up i got done playing
like grime and beat death door i beat
death store in like eight hours that was
actually pretty quick and fun
um
but yeah just like trying to plan ahead
because i'm waiting on a 4k 144 hertz
monitor i ordered one and
literally like waiting to get here flex
i don't have a 4k tv in my house
this is my first 4k display
yeah flex sexy eflex
you see my scrawny arm
hold on it's there
um
because i'm waiting to play final
fantasy 7 integrated ratchet and clank
and death stranding because i want them
to look that good and i knew it was like
i know this monitor is getting here so i
wanted to see how they're meant to be
played so
i've been waiting on some of those
things just to like
see them how they're meant to be shown
in 4k and that's what i'm waiting on so
when that stuff drops i'm like okay now
i gotta plan all these things then elden
ring and then horizon zero dawn i have
four days to not sleep and then play
witch queen i'm like starting to like
plan out my year and all of a sudden
it's getting busy so it's going to be
um interesting to say the least but
honestly yeah we're we are basically
this is intermission go enjoy your week
enjoy your weekend and we will come back
for part two to talk about deep
discussion on trials
void 3.0
anything else that we didn't think about
and season of the lost which we haven't
touched but if you guys are looking for
guides for that lost sectors
collectibles anything check out my
youtube channel that's what i'm working
on right now mostly facts uh but for
this episode for part one of this
episode
august 26th has now began
you know that would actually be a really
good place to cut it get your
concessions
like don't even do our outro because
really it's like part two's next week
thanks
i i'm willing to do that you wanna do
that all right well guys this is gonna
be part two intermission we will finish
this whole discussion next week but at
this point travis take us out
intermission for the last word has now
began
you have less than seven days to grab
some concessions use the bathroom and
take care of any personal phone calls
please remember to turn off your phones
when returning to your seat thank you
and welcome to the last word